Oops, let me turn this off.
My music off.
Senpais!
Don't spoil the game!
Oh shit, you can see my steam library, fuck.
Ahhhh.
Give us a second.
Why aren't you doing DOS?
Why aren't you doing the DOS box?
There it is.
Let's make this a little bit smaller.
I set you up to be
1920 by 1080.
You stupid game.
It's okay.
Welcome Senpais to the stream!
I've literally, literally
set this up so hard.
I've saved it.
I went into the like configuration settings,
changed everything,
and it's still being a little whole.
Anyways, for those who don't know
anything about Harvest Starter,
it is a game made basically as a
protest against censorship.
So what you're going to see is, of course,
a lot of maybe edgier stuff.
You might see me canceled in like a day or two, who knows.
It's very famous for being quite out there.
I still hear the background.
Oh shit.
I was so caught up on seeing,
on making this work that I didn't realize.
There you go.
Wrong one.
There we go.
You just missed a little bit of the opening.
We can watch it again.
Just kidding.
So this is the hatred of past generations.
There's a lot of games and movies
and even animes back in the 90s
that were protest against censorship.
A famous one, a famous anime,
that some of my senpais might know,
it's called General Cyber,
which is, which dubs itself
as the most violent anime ever made.
It's also a protest against censorship as well.
So make sure.
So games of this time,
the censorship was, of course,
due to the...
I think basically the scare where every...
Oh gosh, it's been a while since I did this study.
But at this point, it'll be games that are evil
and makes your kids satanists
and makes your kids all bad and stuff.
And so here, you can just say moral panic.
Mercy, thank you.
Everyone is up in arms about video games.
So what do they do?
They go,
what if we can make it worse?
What if we can make it worse?
So here we are with Arvester.
Oh come on, there we go.
Actually, let me move my screen a little bit for me.
I've set you up to be like the perfect ratio,
and now it's still windowed.
Can you believe it?
So pretty much,
I think this was the time when people saw...
I need to remember, mind you,
I did this study a couple, a few years ago.
So this was a long time ago, so my memory is still shot.
But this is probably like...
Was it Nightcrawler?
Nightcrawler, kind of like scare moral panic there.
Where, you know, Nightcrawler is like a bunch of creeper,
like ninja things.
Night trap, yes.
Not Nightcrawler.
Yeah, Nighttrap, where a bunch of ninja things
are coming in for these girls' sleepovers.
Did you tweet you are alive?
No?
I guess I'll go do that now, Senpai.
I guess I'll do that now, Senpai.
I can't believe.
I always forget.
I think I'm still in the mindset of...
Hold on, I need to get the...
What do you call it?
The thumbnail, and then I gotta...
And then I'll post it up.
I have to go to the waiting room and everything.
Not the waiting room, the stream.
And post it up too.
Oh boy, I reminded myself earlier, I'll do it.
And then I got distracted by pretzels.
I got distracted by chocolate-covered pretzels.
So I ate a few.
And a piece of cheese.
Okay, give me a second.
Sorry, Senpais.
I think I'm still not quite used to being...
Being, you know, here.
Let's go to my YouTube studio.
Content.
And let's do...
Get a shareable link.
Post it right there.
Remove the HTTPS.
Right here.
Am I on the right account? Check.
Oh.
Somebody posted tag me and something, gotta retweet it.
We'll reply to it later.
There we go!
Yay!
I always forget.
I always forget, because...
I don't want to go much into my past life.
Because I want to keep my past life on the down low.
But...
You know, back then I never really made a schedule and just went,
I want to play!
I want to play this! Let's go! Bam!
But yeah, I prefer to keep my past life on the down low,
but since we're allowed in VLOR, just by the way,
we are allowed to talk about our past life in VLOR.
I just want to keep it on the DL,
because, essentially...
Essentially, we are different people.
Now I have to schedule entire weeks beforehand.
Yeah.
Hi, Mercy. What's being harvested?
I'm not sure.
But right now, I'm bringing it up just to tell you why.
To tell you why, I haven't exactly gotten used to...
used to pulsing up that I'm live or anything.
It's like...
What? What? What do you mean, Mercy?
Why are you saying Mercy?
SEMPAI!
Speak!
Okay.
Let's show tips.
Use the right mouse button to attack an opponent.
Okay.
Left click on your character or press I to view inventory.
Left click on an object to grab it,
and right click to put it in inventory.
A penny saved is hardly worth the effort.
Use the left mouse button to move your character around the screen.
If you're stuck on a puzzle, talk to other characters,
and they will give you clues.
Avoid cliches like the plague.
Ammunition is precious, so don't waste it.
If you get stuck in a puzzle, try using items in crazy, illogical ways.
Okay, yeah, that's... that's part...
That's part of the...
That's part of point and click, so let's be real.
Save your game often,
especially before trying something crazy, illogical, or dangerous.
Holding down the control button plus the arrow keys allow you to attack opponents.
Look before you leap.
The help screen can be helpful, or better yet, read the manual.
Speaking of, I haven't read the manual.
It's a point and click with combat, it seems.
You can pick your friends, and you can pick your nose,
but you can't pick your friend's nose.
Oh yeah, bet!
This has a manual. Yeah, it looks like it has a manual.
I can pull it up, probably.
I'd have to... have to pull it up, though.
Right clicking on objects in inventory shows a close-up of that object.
Right clicking on weapons in inventory activates and deactivates them.
Press escape to bring up menu options.
You can combine objects into new objects by clicking and dragging items on one another.
Sound levels can be adjusted in the options menu.
Screen too dark, try adjusting the gamma on the option menu.
Check your photo on the inventory screen.
It will get worse as you take more damage.
Look for special items that will restore your health.
After finding required items during the day, night will be the time of mischievous adventure.
Double-click the left mouse button on an exit to go through instantly.
Use the right mouse button to attack an opponent.
Oh wait, okay, whatever, we're going back in circles now.
Thank you!
Let's look around!
A pair of plastic binoculars with lenses melted onto the table.
How hot is it?
An empty acne medication container.
Ah, we're teens.
A photo of a beautiful girl blonde about 17 years old.
A sexy pinup.
I can't, I can't whistle.
Psst!
Never mind.
One of your typical wall clocks.
I've never seen a wall clock like that ever!
Paper doll by the mill's brother sits on the turntable.
You know, like, record players are really popular.
Senpai, do you have a record player?
The dresser drawer is unlocked.
Open it then!
I take a 25 cent piece dated 1952.
Take it.
Chew marks are visible on the end of this ballpoint pen.
As of yet, the future isn't so bright.
Can I take it?
Is there anything else in here?
We're good.
About any other drawers?
Oh no, it's just the one drawer.
Okay.
You peer through a thin layer of dust at your reflection.
Seven flannel shirts accompanied with matching blue jeans
are hanging neatly in the closet.
I have records, but no record player.
I got a tape player.
I have a tape player too!
It's like a tape player and radio.
I found it, I found it in the shed.
I found it in the shed.
It's Bugs Bunny.
It's got Bugs Bunny on it.
Actually, remember getting this tape player.
Okay, here.
Let's walk, mister.
Oh, what's in the trash can?
An empty trash can, so clean you can eat from it.
Anything else?
Did this require anything?
Oh, maybe the drawer?
No.
The mattress is speckled with odd stains.
A 148 scale P47 Thunderbolt with a broken propeller.
How about this one?
A hastily glued P51 Mustang in exactly a 136 scale.
Oh, oh no!
Oh no, Senpai!
Oh no!
I'm gonna have to BRB real fast.
I think I have an idle meeting.
I have an idle meeting I must attend right now.
Build
Are you playing ping pong again Senpai?
Get back into your cages and start watching me!
I did wash my hands, yes I did.
You want to watch me game or what?
Did Marcy pull an Emmy?
What the Emmy pull?
Your finger?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I haven't even told about the mom yet?
Who's mom?
I'm gonna save the game just in case I step out of this room and then I decide to die.
Oh my gosh, a box of crayons and a range rider coloring book.
What's this?
Fine bone china gleams from the mahogany shelves.
Can I look at the crack in the ceiling?
Why is there so many?
Okay, first off, why is there two fire extinguishers?
A box full of newspapers.
That's a lot of newspapers.
The stunning depiction of the earth made of paper mache.
Not even plastic, okay.
This house is very safety conscious.
Everything was flammable, okay.
What?
Who are you?
You wouldn't.
Mom.
Do you know me?
I am a shit brother.
Mom, Steve is bugging me.
Okay.
Yo, lousy rat.
Listen here, you little shit.
I'm actually the youngest sibling, so I was the little shit.
Steve.
Wow, we have such a short temper.
You always wear a kidder, Steve.
I'm sick.
Uh, tell me about your cowboy show.
On TV?
You think?
Yeah, I think so too.
Blood and guts are needle.
What should I say, Senpai?
Should I be the half full big brother?
Or should I just be like, yeah, you're right.
That's really neat.
You're not too bad for a lousy rat.
It's like they're talking about any.
I said any like a belly button.
Sick.
What's wrong with you?
I'm gonna watch my cowboy show.
So shut up.
Shut up.
Magnesia stuff.
I don't understand.
Okay kid, you're being a lot of stuff.
You're saying you're doing a lot of foreshadowing here.
That I don't know what you're foreshadowing.
Mercy, don't look up any of the names in this game.
Like Steve?
Don't worry.
You want creepy child mode?
You have to sing lullapies very quietly.
Have you noticed that your show...
Oh wait.
I already picked that one.
Alright, it's really neat.
What's this other?
Well, I can type stuff.
Stinky.
Say what?
You're adopted.
Ring around the rosy.
You know like...
Rock-a-bye baby on a tree top.
When the wind blows, the cradle will rock.
When the bow breaks, the cradle will fall.
And down will come baby, cradle and all.
Is that creepy for you guys?
This baby freaking fell from a tree.
No?
It's not creepy.
I guess like another one you think about it.
You singing it didn't sound creepy.
Mary, Mary, oh contrary.
How does your garden grow?
Have cockroach shells?
And I forgot was...
What's the other flower?
Something rhymes with bells.
And pretty maids all laid in a row.
Wait, did we ask about daddy yet?
Your dad is asleep?
He and mom went at it last night pretty hard.
Wait what?
He stayed in bed.
I saw what she did to him.
It was pretty bad.
What did she...
What is she?
Like you don't know.
I saw you and her on the couch last Wednesday night.
Guess that's why she's grounded now, huh?
Too bad you wouldn't pay me and I had to tell, huh?
What are you talking about?
What girl?
What?
Is there another one too?
Wait till I tell.
Ezra!
Welcome to the stream!
Welcome Raiders!
Sorry, did I miss that?
But did we just...
You know, did we just f*** our mom?
Or did we f*** someone else?
Ask, ask what?
I have to ask?
No wait, he said something about the couch.
Like I saw you and mom on the couch and I'm like...
Okay fine, I'll ask it right there.
Oh Ezra, you're making me blush.
Oh you're such a kidder.
You're making me blush, Ezra.
Now he just said her.
Her, her.
Okay, her is girl.
Okay, let me check.
Girl.
I don't know what girl you're talking about.
All summer, it's been Stephanie this.
Stephanie that.
And now you don't remember?
You think I'm dumb or something?
No, I just can't remember anything like I said.
Well you better remember quit.
Cause the wedding's in two weeks.
What?
Leave me alone so I can watch TV.
TV?
That's a weird looking television.
Come to think of it, this whole place looks totally retro.
What do you mean retro?
All TVs look alike.
Sure, basically.
You didn't say mom.
This whole fashion clunker.
Whole fashion?
Looks brand new.
Yeah, but look at the tube.
Where's the remote control?
Where's the tube?
What's that?
No but I think about it.
I can't remember.
And what was that you said?
I thought retro rockets?
No, retro, it means...
It means...
Oh man, I know what I mean.
That everything here is wrong.
But I can't picture the difference.
And shut up and quit bugging me.
I'm lost in my cowboy show.
What wedding?
Wait, hold on.
First off.
What else?
Well, I...
Yeah, you're right.
It's great.
Okay, shut up.
What wedding?
Say what?
Pick your nose.
I saw the nose wrong.
No.
Say what?
Boop.
Adopt it.
Say what?
You're adopted, kid.
Try Stephanie.
Stephanie.
Say what?
Oh fuck this kid.
Good.
Finally.
Wait till I get my grabby little hands on you.
We're at...
Good.
Let me alone, Claudia.
This is the good part.
I see.
Uh, was it Stephanie Girl?
I don't know what girl you're talking about.
Thank you.
All summer, it's been Stephanie this and Stephanie that.
And now you don't remember?
You think I'm dumb or something?
No, I just can't remember anything, like I said.
Well, you better remember quit.
Because the wedding's in two weeks.
What?
Let me alone so I can watch TV.
Stephanie.
I said I don't want to talk about her anymore.
I said...
All right.
See ya.
Good.
Man, what a bratty brother I have.
Just spank him.
Is that mom?
What's this?
An expertly embroidered old fashioned wall plaque.
Cookies are baking in the oven.
A newborn is sleeping soundly.
A cabinet that smells of dirty diapers.
Dirty diapers?
Shouldn't they be clean?
Have you tried putting the entire English dictionary into the chat box
and tried to trigger everything at once?
I don't think so.
These cookies are hot out of the oven.
All right.
Oh, there is.
Uh-huh.
Oh, he says Josh.
What job?
We've already established this, Steve.
I'm going to fall asleep to Marysie.
You may fall asleep to me.
Hold on.
Mwah.
Now, tuck you in.
Here you go.
I have a sister?
Oh, wait.
Is it the baby?
The baby?
The baby.
OK.
Let's go through all this.
Graduation.
When did we graduate?
Four months ago.
All you need to get a job.
And besides, you can't marry Stephanie if you're going to waste your time going to college.
This is the first time I've ever seen someone say,
don't go to college.
It's a disgrace, but better late than never.
I guess we can thank Stephanie for that.
All right.
This is the first.
All right, Stephanie.
And just who is Stephanie?
Don't you dare toy with that sweet girl.
If you start in on her with all this amnesia poop,
she'll think her fiance is having second thoughts about the wedding.
Wedding?
Look, all this talk about weddings is nuts.
I'm not marrying anybody till I figure out what's going on here.
First, the heartbreak of psoriasis.
Psoriasis?
Two weeks before the wedding and you're backing out.
Whatever will the neighbors think?
I can't marry someone I don't even know.
Fine, have it your way, but leave me out of it.
If you're going to break Stephanie's heart,
you march right next door and do it yourself.
And don't expect me to write you a note.
Okay.
Fiance?
This is insane.
Oh, you're not having second thoughts about marrying Stephanie.
Is that what this silliness is all about?
Pre-wedding jitters?
Can something like that produce amnesia?
Stop this foolishness right now and count your blessings.
Stephanie is great at cooking and cleaning.
Cooking and cleaning?
What's cooking and cleaning got to do with anything?
Honestly, boys are so dense.
What else is there for a wife but cooking and cleaning?
You may not appreciate a hot meal on a clean plate when it's there,
but if it wasn't, we'd hear about it soon enough, I'll bet.
You're saying that's all there is to marriage.
Cooking and cleaning?
No!
You'll have to ask your father about that,
but I'm sure Stephanie will do her duty.
Her duty?
Don't worry so far.
I'll do my duty too when we get married.
Marriage is more than cooking and cleaning.
It's about loving each other
and being there for each other for all of eternity.
Right?
I said right!
Okay.
Good!
So fly, good!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha!
Someone say no?
Mom, scut off his testicles!
Are there testicles?
I don't actually know.
Thank you!
Thank you, mods!
You're welcome.
You'll have them back once Emmy wakes up.
Okay, let's talk about our duty.
Or should we talk about our father?
Ha ha, duty.
They grow back?
They always grow back, don't you know?
We should talk about duty, huh?
Disgusting truths.
Lexingogos?
Your baby was Stephanie.
You'll have to make your peace with the fact that
when a farmer plants his seed,
he can't help but get some nasty dirt on his hoe.
Not on his hoe!
Mother!
You can't use such language around here.
We should treasure the love they have.
Or maybe if there's no love.
You know what?
If there's no love, no marriage, okay?
But clearly, there has to be love.
Oh, why goggles?
Goggles is such a strange thing.
You know, like, goggle boots, right?
Like, they're really long boots.
Oh, let's talk about our father now.
My father.
He's in the other room.
He decided to sleep in today.
Now please, let me get back to my cookies.
Cookies?
The bake sale was on Friday,
and yet you're baking the cookies now.
Never put off till tomorrow what you can do today.
But they'll be stale by then.
That's why I'm throwing them away.
And then cooking more?
To replace the ones I throw out.
Why?
Well, I have to.
No one's going to pay to eat stale cookies out of the garbage can.
But you expect me to?
Of course not, Steve.
I wouldn't charge you.
I'm your mother.
Help yourself.
You would charge me to eat cookies out of the trash can?
You wouldn't have done that, mommy?
All right.
Let's get some garbage cookies.
What charity is this bake sale supposed to benefit?
It'll help provide a fund for bums and hobos who wander into harvest
and have no family ties.
Kind of a specific target group, isn't it?
Yeah, that's pretty specific to detail when dealing with such people.
I don't know what you mean.
You will.
The whole thing has been organized by the lodge.
The lodge?
What lodge?
What's so great about it?
It sounds like a call.
No one gets inside, but it wouldn't be so exclusive if it wasn't just wonderful.
Just like the new Reynolds dishwasher with their patented auto dry process TM.
I've never used one, but I know I want it.
Instead of sulking around the house all day,
why not walk over to the lodge and apply for membership?
The last thing I want is a fizz on my head.
Don't be so hasty, Steve.
I think you'll find harvest is a pretty dull place without the lodge.
You sound like the membership director.
Don't be silly.
I just want what's best for you.
That's all.
Harvest, harvest.
I don't remember the song.
Nice product placement, though.
I think my dishwasher is over 20 years old.
Harvest is a town unlike any you've ever known.
In what way?
Yeah.
I don't have time to go into it now.
Why not take a walk around town and pester someone else?
I'm busy.
Okay, bye, mom.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
You know how he gets.
Wait, we put the papers out for Jimmy?
Freshly baked cookies are in the trash can.
Can I take a look at them?
Well, I guess I'll grab.
Yeah, it's there.
House indicator.
I'm fine.
Harvest land, furniture, warehouse.
Okay.
The master bedroom door is firmly locked.
Is that my father?
I could have taken a look at the baby.
I can newborn baby is sleeping soundly.
He's eating.
Now he doesn't sound healthy.
Sounds like one of my, my senpai's dad.
Oh boy.
Now I'm squealing wickedly in the kitchen's antiseptic glow.
Mom.
I told you I'm busy, Steve.
Why don't you talk to him?
I'm busy.
Steve, why don't you talk to Hank
or go next door and visit Stephanie
or go get an early start on your new job.
Hank?
Hank.
That kid over by the television?
Your little brother is home sick from school today
and I won't have you scaring him with this amnesia poop.
Is he really sick?
Look at the show he's watching.
Wouldn't you say he's sick?
I'd make him stop, but oh, I'm so busy
baking cookies for the Harvest PPA charity bake sale.
It's on Friday, you know.
I hope you're still planning on going.
I don't know.
I need to think.
Honestly, skipping out of a charity affair.
What's gotten into you?
I don't know.
Damn it.
That's what I'm telling you.
Don't you dare use that language around me.
Oh, my goodness.
Your father didn't hear you or Stephanie
for that matter.
How do you think she'd feel knowing her fiance was a gutter mess?
Wait, did I talk about my father yet?
Didn't I foul a language?
Shit.
Stop speaking nonsense, dear.
Bitch.
Fuck.
What a thing to say to your mother.
Was that an invitation now that your father is out of action?
I'm flabbergasted.
I guess we got to pick the first one.
We got to pick the first one.
I guess we have to pick the first one.
I mean, everyone has as around the line, right?
Well, we're here.
Let's go.
Yeah, how about it, mommy?
Maybe later, dear.
Right now I have housework to do.
So you can watch if you want.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
You know how he gets.
My mouth is a gait.
She said maybe later.
We got a maybe?
There's a glow from behind the cabinet.
Can I punch my bro?
What do I do if I say fuck to him?
No, nothing, OK.
Bye.
Why is there a glow there?
Can I?
Come on, walk.
What's that glow?
Can I push it?
Remember to say before you do anything crazy,
I got the paper.
Right here, I have the paper.
What happened?
What is this?
What a bag!
What a bag in the inventory!
Oh no, is this the paper?
What did I do, Aya?
Aya!
Tempai!
It's stuck!
Can you hear that?
It's making the t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t sound.
Now everything's frozen!
Aya!
Aya, Tempai!
Don't look, Tempai!
Don't look at my...
No, that's not it.
Don't look at my steam.
Oh now it decides to play in fullscreen stupid game.
Never mind, I decided not to go in fullscreen anymore.
Hello?
Are you gonna...
Are you gonna show up?
Okay, there we go. We're fine now.
Can I skip?
Wait, no, I have a save file. Load game.
Or okay.
Guess we should save more often.
Okay, let's skip through this.
Eddie.
Girl.
Stephanie.
Phoebe.
There we go.
I saved before the brother, which sucks.
Cowboy.
Oops.
Bye.
Guess we go talk to mom now.
At least we can speedrun him being a brat, yeah.
Talk to mom.
Okay.
Stephanie.
Wedding.
Beyonce.
Cooking and cleaning.
Father.
Cookies.
Uh, job. I remember it was job.
I didn't actually talk about the job. What was my job?
Just like anybody else.
Oh, my dad's work? Slaughterhouse.
Mom, your voice changed.
Uh, did we talk about lodge again?
Uh, why not? I go look into it.
Harvest.
Uh, I guess we can say, does anyone else know if we can say something else?
Cause, I don't know, I guess we can do this again.
It still shocks me each time.
Dirty diapers. Knives.
Embroidery.
Let's get out of here.
Escape save game.
Let's save it over this game file.
Let's get box one newspapers. Let's grab the newspaper.
I said grab the newspaper.
I wonder if, if, if I need to, if I, if I can check it.
Let's save again.
Let's save again to see if that newspaper breaks again.
Can I, how do I look at it? Does anyone remember how to look at it?
I guess it didn't break again.
Did I double click? I can't remember how to look at it. Right click to look at it.
Well, it's not, not doing anything.
Now, whatever.
This kid wants the paper, right?
Here you go.
No.
Hey Steve, you've been doing a swell drop putting the paper out in the morning.
You just keep doing that and we won't have any problems. That's not much to ask, is it?
No.
See you later alligator.
Okay, see you later alligator.
Full of junk, mail, bills and bake sale flyers.
Is that? There are security bars fastened to the window with Phillip head screws.
The day glow lima space disc stuck on the roof.
An Army surplus air conditioner.
Okay, this kid's acting a little hard for like, you know.
See you later alligator.
Okay, so I have to give him the paper every day.
Can I see the paper?
Your house, general store or Stephanie's house?
Oh, huh?
Potsdam's residence.
The garage needs some new paint job.
Glass is so clear the reflection makes it difficult to see.
Must have rained recently.
That window is shaped like a wagon wheel.
Hi.
The man of the house squeezing his mate.
Wait, I soft blocked myself. What do you mean?
There he is, my future son-in-law. And how's he doing today?
What brings him to the Potsdam household?
I came to see Stephanie.
Oh, you'll have to ask the missus about that.
Stephanie's grounded to the wedding.
Can't have her changing her mind at the last minute. Not with all that meat at stake.
Me?
I haven't seen my father. He's locked in a room.
He's not going to die, is he?
Like I said, I don't know. That woman, Mom, tends to him herself.
Well, next time you see him, be sure to tell him that I said hello.
And tell him that I'm praying for his speedy recovery.
And also, would you remind him about the meat? Especially about the meat?
Yeah, fine. If I see him.
You should be concerned. If he dies, then who's going to take over the slaughterhouse?
Who's going to tend to the meat?
Why is it meat?
You'd take over, right?
Slaughterhouse?
I can't imagine a better job than working in a slaughterhouse.
I think working in a slaughterhouse might be cool.
Bite your tongue with that serpent's tooth. Your dead slaughterhouse is the most successful business in harvest.
Oh, okay. Never mind. You got me angry at that.
You'll love it there.
Oh, sure. Cutting animals open may not be much fun. Reaching into their bodies...
Uh-huh.
Oh, wait. Actually, this is fine.
...testing, dangling, and slapping against you the smell of death and shit in your nostrils all the time.
That's fine.
Those are all definite cons of what you're done.
The guts have been washed into the gutters. What have you left with them?
Meat.
Rose and rose.
Did the audio go weird?
Is that supposed to happen?
Was that supposed to happen?
That was a little bit spooky. That was kind of spooky. That surprised me when that happened.
Yeah, let's talk more about the meat.
Oh.
I might have to turn the volume down if that happens again.
Meat is the foundation of any decent society.
Everyone needs at least five servings of red meat a day.
And anyone who says otherwise is a commie.
A commie?
And once you're married to Stephanie, I'll be part of the family, too.
And your father will give me all the meat I want.
Time to make some for not getting into the lodge.
It sounds so grainy.
Is that supposed to happen?
Did I break the game?
Again?
Or is it just like that?
Yeah, let's talk about the meat.
I don't like how he's talking about father's meat. Yeah, me neither.
Meat is the foundation of any decent society. Everyone needs at least three servings of red meat a day.
Alright, we already asked about that. Got it, father.
I haven't seen my father.
Like I said.
Well, next time you see him.
Yeah, fuck.
You should be more concerned.
Um...
Bye?
Also, almost made of leather.
It's polyester.
The upholster you stained after years of profuse sweating.
A futary urn in this cabinet so occupant.
A giant mutant asparagus?
Inexplicably robust given the fact that it's encased in red concrete.
Perhaps the health... healthful electromagnetic fields of harvest.
Why is it sounding like this?
Hello, Steve. Have you lost a day?
You look just like my mom except for the hair.
Honestly, you man can insult a woman without even knowing you've done it.
What a horrible thing to say.
Oh, you don't like my mom?
Same kind of dress. Same pearls.
So bizarre.
There's nothing bizarre about baking cookies.
The harvest charity bake-so is Friday, you know, and by gosh,
Mrs. Marvin Potson Jr. can be counted on to do her share.
Pearls.
Just because I'm doing housework doesn't mean I have to be a drudge.
It's a wife's duty to look good for her husband at all times.
What's wrong with wearing pearls for heaven's sake?
Nothing, but you look like June Cleaver.
Some kind of sitcom, Mom.
sitcom?
Geez, you know, a situation comedy.
The weird part is, I can't remember how I know that.
I'm much too busy with housework to watch TV.
Maybe Mr. Potson would know about sitcoms.
sitcoms?
Somebody doesn't watch TV though. She's grounded.
Why is she grounded?
Mr. Potson feels there's too much at stake to allow Stephanie to run around with.
She doesn't want to get married either, huh?
Uh-huh.
Are you saying you don't want to marry my daughter?
I don't know your daughter, Mrs. Potson.
Why is she grounded?
Afraid she'll run away before the wedding?
No.
She's as delighted as we are about the wedding.
Every bit as delighted as we are.
But she might be hit by a car or a fallen piano.
Or who knows what?
A fallen piano?
Mr. Potson wants us all to be one happy family.
And he doesn't want to risk anything happening at the last minute.
You please let her out of her room, please.
Not a chance, Steve.
Mr. Potson wouldn't like it.
If you'd like to see her, it's fine with me.
Go upstairs and turn right.
Now, excuse me.
I'm trying to get ready for the bake sale.
Mr. Potson.
You mustn't be too hard on Mr. Potson, Steve.
He's a disappointed man.
No matter how many large admission forms he fills out,
they keep turning him down.
He has a new application in, though,
so keep your fingers crossed.
If he joins the lodge,
you and Stephanie can have your wedding in the Chapel of Love
rather than over at Moynihan's place.
Mr. what?
Moynihan?
Mr. Moynihan runs the Wayward Hotel
and the Shady Oaks Funeral Parlor.
It's rumored he has connections with the lodge,
but the order keeps that kind of thing safe.
So Mr. Potson has tried to get him to put in a good word
for his lodge application?
But so far...
Lodge?
What can you tell me about the lodge?
Just that they're exclusive and secretive.
If you're curious, you ought to pick up a lodge application
at the post office and take it over to the Sergeant at Arms.
Isn't that a thought?
Forget Mr. Potson.
If you became a member of the order,
we could hold the wedding inside the lodge.
My, wouldn't that be lovely?
Okay.
Tell me about this wedding.
Wedding?
Well, it's set for three weeks.
We're holding it over at Shady Oaks,
Mr. Moynihan's funeral parlor.
Wedding in a funeral?
It's not a very romantic place,
but there's nowhere else to hold it.
Thanks to Mr. Potson.
You mustn't be too hard...
Give my regards to your parents.
Wait, wait, what if I say those words?
Yes, please.
She's upstairs.
What if I say fuck again?
Sorry, I didn't catch that.
Shit.
Is that really, is that really,
is mom the only one that responds to that?
Icebox is locked.
Our kitchen is a minty fresh looking scent.
Pushes are preventing it from opening.
A plastic plant with freshly watered soil,
and with little styrofoam balls.
Our kitchen has a minty fresh look.
Minty fresh look, minty fresh look.
Okay, got it.
Upstairs we go then.
Duck.
A thin layer of hair coats
virtually every inch of ceramic.
Our duck has seen better days.
He's purty.
This window affords a spectacular view of aluminum siding.
A picture on the wall is hanging a bit crooked.
Ah!
Medicine cabinet reeks of various toiletries.
Can I grab tampons?
Better ask Stephanie about those.
You're here to roll the tube from the bottom.
New zippy vitamins will pick you right up.
Got a headache?
This aspirin should do the trick.
You are of extra strength or a lube.
Great for getting in and out of tight spots.
Give me that.
One hour cough medicine.
Morning yeast disinfectant.
Not to be used for baking cookies.
Give me that.
Give me that too.
And those.
Thanks.
Plants.
Fully yoded.
I don't look around the room, sorry.
Yes, nice taste.
That's it?
I guess I can talk to her?
Who are you?
What are you doing in my room?
Haven't you heard?
We're getting married.
So, you're the one.
Steve, isn't it?
You mean, you don't know me?
You don't know me?
Yeah, what's going on?
Those people?
This actress and her VA are the same person.
Oh, okay.
Steve has a different one for some reason.
Maybe his voice wasn't Steve enough.
Alright, let's talk about those people.
I know what you mean, I don't belong here.
Dang it.
Okay, fair.
Yeah, I get it.
Yeah, I understand.
Both grounded.
Okay, grounded.
Have you seen or heard anything?
Anything else?
Huh?
Did dad put that people in then?
Mr. Potsdam?
Escape.
I think you're right.
Harvest blood drive, huh?
Alright, alright.
Amnesia.
Oh, does that mean bombs?
I have had these recurring dreams.
Just fragments, really.
Strange, abstract images.
Liquid, chrome.
Chrome?
Probably just a dream.
Well, have you thought about how to escape harvest?
Well, what's escape?
Harvest is a pri-
You're too eccentric.
You haven't been locked in your room for a week.
Okay, can I say fuck to her?
You're not making sense.
Never mind.
Duty?
You're not making sense.
Okay, bye.
Come back and visit me soon, okay?
Okay.
Damn, it must be boring.
That rope looks about red meat
and its importance to living well.
These books are obviously fakes.
Makeup looks just fine.
A closet door won't budge.
Okay, well.
Here we go.
Only with the mom is wild.
Why is it only with the mommy?
Peep.
No.
Bathroom?
Oh.
Ah!
Two!
Three!
Should I try all of them?
Everyone's saying two.
Okay, let's do two.
Obviously Mrs. Pops to Mrs. B.
Ruin his marriage?
Kohai, did you save?
I didn't save.
When was the last time I saved before I brought the paper out?
Okay, let's do two.
Ah!
Mrs. Potsdam has a little problem.
I'll handle it myself.
Thanks for calling this to my attention, Steve.
Then you won't mind if I tell Stephanie about it?
Now, there's no need to scare Stephanie with this business.
I guess not.
So long as you patch that hole.
Well, I guess I could hang that picture somewhere else.
I thought you had no idea where it was.
Hall?
Beg pardon?
Even...
Looks like the house's previous owner was a pervert!
I thought you had no idea where it was.
Hall?
Beg pardon?
You've got a peephole in the upstairs bathroom.
It looks in on Stephanie's room.
Well, I'll be darned.
You've been spying on your daughter, haven't you?
How dare you!
I'm no peeping Tom.
I had no idea that was there.
Then you won't mind if I tell Stephanie about it?
Now, there's no need to scare Stephanie with this business.
I guess not.
So long as you patch that hole.
Well, I guess I could hang that picture somewhere else.
I thought you had no idea where it was.
We're telling Stephanie.
Maybe I'll save.
I'll save, but I'm telling Stephanie.
I'm telling her!
Okay, cool, but, uh, hole.
They're spying on me?
I'm afraid so.
So, that's the scraping I hear every night.
The picture sliding along the wall.
Disgusting.
I've got to get out of here, Steve.
The thought of that fat slob.
Watching me.
I confronted Pott's stem about it.
He tried to play dumb, but I got him to say he'd fix it.
Thank you, Steve.
I don't know what I'd do without you.
Come back and visit me soon, okay?
Make this save in slot two, okay?
Sam pie.
Hmm? Huh?
You go ahead and fix that, right, Sam pie?
Hmm.
I played the fifth, but I see Azra's in yours.
Why is mine not there too, Sam pie?
Hmm?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I'm sure I'll hear the excuses.
But it'll be the last excuse you ever make.
Okay, Sam pie?
It's a glitch and I can't see it.
You think I'm blind, Sam pie?
You think I can't fucking see?
It's because I have an eye patch.
Huh? Huh? Huh? Huh? Huh?
I can take it off right now and I can see perfectly fine.
Sam pie?
Huh?
Please be lenient.
I expect to see at least a broken heart if you're not allowed to put in scissors.
Or maybe another heart.
A full heart because that's what you're going to do, Sam pie,
is that you're going to put my broken heart together
and you're going to love me forever, right?
Why would I wear one eye patch if I have two eyes?
You didn't watch my debut?
Sam pie?
You should know if you watched my debut.
Uh huh, uh huh.
Well, Sam pie.
I'm sure two of you can fit into one barrel, right?
I'm sure two of you can fit into one barrel.
If you don't, a bone saw will come in handy.
Oh, you have amnesia.
Do you just like Steve and Stephanie?
But we're not in harvest here.
We're not in harvest here, Sam pie.
We are in harvest in the game, but you're in my basement.
That's not harvest.
Do you really love me, Sam pie?
Say it.
Say that you love me.
Sam pie.
Right now.
Say it.
Say it!
Hmm.
Uh huh, uh huh.
I didn't see all of you say you love me.
Did you lie?
Did you lie to me, Sam pie?
Is that what you're saying?
You're lying to me?
Of course.
No lies, right?
You don't love me.
Right?
I love you, Sam pie.
So make sure you don't make me mad again.
Understood.
Well, let's see what's going on here.
Tave game.
That...
The attic window is the perfect nesting ground for wasps.
I don't like wasps.
Oh wait, I can go in?
These are all freaking wasps?
The icebox is sealed shut.
Shut with a wasp, man.
The wasp woman.
The Judeo-Christian rights of sacrifice
and conventional taboos against unbridled pleasure
for the prejudice against wasps.
Do wasps make...
Do wasps make honey?
I don't think wasps make honey.
Okay.
Honey?
Okay, selling versus...
It's not what is produced.
So much as what is performed.
I don't see any particular use for wasps.
Why must everything have a use?
Is there always the determining factor?
More slender, more aerodynamic than the bee.
The wasp is a joy to behold.
Why is the wasp having the harvest logo?
Ju-juicy?
Juicy?
Wasps?
Wasps produce nothing for others,
but only for themselves.
Wasps spill nests and more wasps, nothing more.
They spread into eons and addicts,
not to make honey for supermarkets,
but to buzz and rustle on their own paper,
perpetuating their own agenda,
growing stealthily,
the most relentless of insects.
Aren't those wasps also help pollinate things
as of, like, even by accident?
What are the drawbacks of wasps, ma'am?
Well, as you can see,
the little darlings do love to sting.
Another source of prejudice for the masses,
and another reason to love them.
Bees are like animals,
they sting only for a reason,
for sacrifice.
They have no conception of individual sensation
of pleasure.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, pleasure?
Yes.
A great deal of pleasure.
The wasp is an individual being,
not a laborer,
hedonistic instead of industrial.
Someone needs to anger.
In truth, they are easily swayed to ecstasy.
They penetrate your throats,
and the muscular contractions in their thorax,
as they pump venom,
could be likened to the muscular contractions
of ejaculation,
each painful welt,
an act of love.
I don't think that was for pleasure.
I don't think that was for pleasure, just said.
Sacrifice?
It's audacity.
This appeals to those raised worshipping of God,
that demand sacrifice and atonement.
But the wasp is promiscuous.
Promiscuous?
They are not as sympathetic to the masses,
because they do die when they sting.
They live to sting another day,
and they take pleasure from it.
They do?
I don't know anything about,
I don't know anything about wasp,
to interject with this.
Juicy?
What did you mean by juicy?
A triviality.
Look.
Sting? Sting?
A triviality.
Um...
Wasp girl?
Stop talking about gen 2.
But maybe I'll pass that idea on to mummy.
Maybe.
I guess wasp is...
Okay, I guess all of you guys are turned on by wasp now.
I guess senpais really love wasp now, right?
That means senpais want me to trap them
in a shed full of wasp, right?
Please, no.
I'll let them loose in the basement.
Yeah, maybe I'll just stuff out of the basement,
and I'll let them all loose.
I'll collect all of them.
If that's what you want.
Wasp outfit?
What?
You want me to be like,
I'm a sexy wasp.
Sexy wasp.
So silly.
Anything else?
Yes.
A great deal of each.
Do you like bees?
A triviality.
Hive?
Fridge?
Okay, maybe I'll do fridge.
Fridge.
A triviality.
Um, lodge?
Can I do the lodge?
A triviality.
Harvest?
Queen?
A triviality.
Try triviality?
Triv.
How do I spell triviality?
Triv...
Triviality.
A triviality.
She focuses on wasps only.
Pollination.
A triviality.
Wasp.
Wow, okay, never mind then, I guess. Bye!
Anything else I can grab in here?
From the sound of it, these cabinets are infested with wasps.
A rather colorful picture
of a wasp.
A wasp nest.
Okay.
An old car is the perfect nesting ground
for a wasp.
Okay.
A general store?
What's this?
Tapes and broken glass.
Obviously a professional break-in.
He's too busy working to notice you.
Air-conditioned!
Yum-creamed asparagus.
Two for forty-nine.
Zero forty-nine.
Yum-creamed asparagus.
No?
Harvest bake sale this Friday
in the school gym.
What's this?
Free copies made here.
Okay.
To add roaches and bits of
agrid grit,
coat the water coolers bone-dry
reservoir.
This empty barrel reeks
of rotting meat.
Who are you?
Helps?
Everybody says I'm a kidder.
What do you mean, willies?
Speak your woolly!
Uh, yeah, please.
Oh, what?
Chef contains an odd
item for sale.
Orange?
Tape?
Wait, sorry.
What was that?
An adult magazine for twenty-five cents.
You must pay Mrs. Phelps
before you buy anything.
A slightly used wrench.
You must pay Mrs. Phelps
before you buy anything.
A cow is bleeding
a robust coffee
on these harvest blend coffee can labels.
Cans of soup!
Or possibly rat poison.
Black electrical tape.
You must pay Mrs. Phelps before you can buy anything.
I don't have any money
except to buy the Dirty magazine.
Should I buy the
the Dirty magazine
zine senpai?
I'm gonna use a wrench and tape for mercy.
I have lots of those.
Yes.
Yeah, let's have, yeah, let's pay for it!
Where's my items?
There we go.
My quarter.
Here you go.
Only thing a quarter will buy is an adult magazine.
A girly magazine?
Yeah!
I've been in here ogling the girly magazines
behind my counter.
Darned if I'd sell him one though.
I know his wife for heaven's sakes.
Well, will you sell me one?
I certainly will Steve.
That kind of interest is healthy
for a young fellow.
Stares him away from being a
fireman.
What's wrong with the fireman?
So am I getting it?
I got it!
Wait, let's save before we look at it.
Let's save before we look at it,
because I feel like if I don't say
it's gonna do that weird thing again.
Let me look at it!
Can I look at it?
Why? Why can't I look at it?
I got it!
I wanted to look at the girly magazine!
I wanted to see the dirty magazines.
The dirty magazines.
I wanted to look at the dirty magazines.
You're not allowed to look at the dirty
You're not allowed to look at the dirty magazines.
Senpai.
But you can with me.
We're just gonna have to imagine it.
I can't even look at the paper.
You're gonna read a dirty mag on stream?
It's not, it's not bad
if it's a part of a game.
What about dirty magazines of you?
Of me?
I don't think there's any.
But wouldn't that make you jealous, Senpai?
I don't know.
Although I didn't want to see it
because I was like, oh what's in
what's in the dirty magazine?
Okay, well...
Post office?
When do they have signs?
What's this, a crushed paper cup
that you can't see?
Blind woman's trying to read her mail.
Mailboxes seem hardly
hardly used.
Yes?
I need some help.
Mr. Postmaster Boyle.
What can I do for you today?
Boyle?
I'd like a lodge application.
I'm sorry, youngster.
We're out of applications right now.
Come on.
You must have one around here somewhere.
Well, I do have the master,
but you can't write on that.
And I only make copies once a month
on the button, regular as clockwork.
Can I go...
get one at the lodge instead?
Afraid not, son.
You can't get them anywhere but the post office.
I'm sorry, you'll just have to come back in a month.
Same as anyone else.
And even then, I can't guarantee you'll get an application.
The line is always long
and they're never enough to go around.
It's very important that I get in quickly.
That's what they all say.
Postmaster Boyle, I'll just die
if I don't get into the lodge.
Can't make an exception, young man.
Just wouldn't be right.
What?
What's the zip code?
Oh, zip code,
map with the harvest dead center.
I wonder if I can distract him three clocks
three times.
I wonder if I can distract him.
Maybe give Fat Meatman
the dirty magazine
to get an application.
He said something about the sheriff.
So the hint was that the sheriff probably
gets the magazine.
That's what it said before.
So I played enough
pointing clicks to know
that perhaps that is the reason.
Maybe I can go to the barbershop?
I always feel like
before I need to go into a building
I need to save.
Maybe you can trade the magazine
with the blind woman paper.
Enough about the magazine.
It's going to the chief sheriff.
A fancy barber pole
secured to the wall with straight
shot screws.
Why is there an alien up there?
An unfortunate extraterrestrial
who journeyed hundreds of lights years
to wind up mounted to a barber's wall.
Except for his occasional hairball cough
it's hard to tell if the sheep is alive or not.
Made of solidified moose
and sticky hairspray.
This lovely mannequin is a work of art.
It takes a true sportsman to hunt down those dangerous
dogs.
A dangling television is sure to cause
neck strain at this angle.
Call
call, call a note, call a note, Buster Monroe
Colonel
Colonel Colonel Colonel
There you go.
Colonel Buster Monroe flipping
the bird from his B-17
cockpit.
That's a picture of Mr. Pastrilli
as a young buck.
Picture of a young Mr. Pastrilli spaghetti in his mouth and awe.
Howdy Steve.
Yeah. Howdy back, Mr.
It swells, Steve.
Don't disturb my old leg now.
Change your mind about that aluminum siding.
What are you talking about?
I really think you should tuck your father into buying some.
He can afford it.
And I can't stress enough the value of some really fine aluminum siding.
Keeps it warm in the summer, cool in the winter, and it keeps out the shade.
Warm out in the summer and cool in the winter, huh?
No, thank you.
But I can't get him to understand a word I say.
Aluminum siding.
I didn't mean to click him.
I meant to like click something else, but okay.
Aluminum siding.
Steve, aluminum siding can't get a fair shake no more.
Started when those firemen came to harvest, filling people's heads with new fangled notions like color coordination and interior design.
You can paint aluminum, you know, if you want to.
But even so, I can't seem to move it anymore.
Not even to a rouble like Pastrilli.
Thank God for the plumbing.
Are we implying that the firemen are a little...
It's okay.
I'll relate with the firemen.
I love interior design and color coordination.
After all, every time we go on dates, we have to be color coordinated.
So everybody knows that we're a couple.
We'll get along just fine.
Maybe they can give some tips on more interior design.
Maybe I can make the basement more welcoming for my supplies.
Don't you think that'll be great?
Maybe we can wear those like t-shirts that's like...
That's like, I'm his and I'm hers.
The matching collar was enough?
No, we have to have like matching everything.
That'd be cute.
And matching and like promise rings.
Oh, well, let's talk more about Pastrilli.
Pastrilli's a rouble from way back.
Ask Clam Parsons how we followed up with the alarm system in here.
I'm a plumber.
I could fix it for him, but he just won't listen.
I mean...
Well, I've seen the end coming for the aluminum siding game,
so I took a mail course and learned how to be a plumber.
Now, there's a business that never lets up.
You'd be surprised when people flush down the toilet.
You know, fair.
I always need...
Sometimes I had to call a plumber,
but then three plumbers ghosted me.
And then Papa Mercy came to save the day and fixed it.
We fixed it itself.
We fixed it ourselves.
I can't believe plumbers nowadays would just ghost you like that.
Don't they want money?
I don't get it.
I was willing to pay.
But they always ghost.
And I'm just like, why?
So Papa was so sick of it, he just fixed it himself.
Didn't you scare them away? Why would I?
All I said was my shower stopped working.
This is called Papa Modisse first time?
Well, it was Papa Modisse idea to call the plumber first.
And then once the first one...
Once the first one ghosted,
we're like, okay, maybe that one's just busy.
We called a different one. We called another one.
And then that didn't work.
And so we called another one.
And that didn't work.
And like, well, the last one we called,
we waited for like, odd day for him.
And he was a no-show.
He was a no-show.
And then we called the place back and they were like,
oh yeah, tomorrow.
And so we waited another day and he never showed.
And we called back and they were like,
oh yeah, yeah, maybe another day.
And then we're like, you know what?
Can we cancel that?
And so after that, Papa was like,
screw this, I'll do it myself.
And then, and then...
And then he did it himself and he did a great job.
Gave you the window and then no-show?
Yeah, like twice.
All of them did.
I just don't understand plumbers.
Bye-bye.
Nice to see you again, Steve.
Mr. Pastrilli does not respond, not understanding English.
Wait, what?
Is he Italian?
Mamma mia!
Hello there, youngster.
They say them aliens I was telling you about,
they came back last night,
cut another crop circle in the Southfield.
How come I never see none of them saw some plum?
Them aliens is wild, they think.
You don't cross the intergalactic void
without learning a trick or two.
You know what Mr. Pastrilli did?
Yesterday, he gets an alarm system to protect his pole.
Only he don't know how to rig it, so now it's all arrived.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's a job for YouTube tutorials
and multiple chips to the hardware store.
Actually, that's exactly what Papa did,
except for he didn't really...
He doesn't know YouTube.
Speaking of YouTube,
guess what, Senpai, you all have been...
You all have been, um...
promoted from students to fans.
Mama Mercy has figured out what a YouTuber is.
We're making progress!
Except for now, she's been trying to convince me
to do tours of the local Costco.
A film tour of the local Costco.
She's apparently been watching people do show off
what's being bought at, like, what's new products from Costco.
And so she's like, that seems really easy, dear.
Except for now, we have another problem.
We have another problem.
Senpai, we have another problem.
She's now wanting the play button faster.
She wants it faster.
She's like, yeah, you can get it now, right?
I'm sure lots of people will watch.
And now I'm worried.
You think she's gonna find you at any point?
Probably not.
She watches cooking videos in Vietnamese.
She's watching cooking videos and Costco tours,
or store tours, I guess, tours of shops and stuff.
She's getting it!
Not all of it, but she's getting it.
When do we get a cooking stream with Kohai?
To be honest, I'm a little clumsy.
Mama, last time I tried to go in the kitchen,
Mama said, get out.
Don't worry, I'll try my best for you, Senpai.
But last time she said...
She said, uh...
I'm too clumsy to be in the kitchen.
Yeah!
I mean, I don't blame her.
You want to hear a funny story?
So I was trying to cut strawberries with a fruit knife.
And if you didn't know,
fruit knives, the sharp part is not the curved part.
The sharp part is the flat side.
You can see where I'm getting at, right?
So I was cutting strawberries,
and I was having trouble cutting the strawberries.
And Mama looked at me and said,
it's upside down.
And you know what I did?
I flipped the strawberry and not the knife,
and continued trying to cut it.
I got it in the end when she grabbed the knife
and put it down to the flat side instead.
Well, I'm not used to fruit knives, you know?
So I just assumed the sharp side was the curved side.
How did you survive this long?
I have no idea, to be honest.
Like knife, you know?
You're used to the curved side being the sharp part,
but on a fruit knife it's not that part.
But the flat end.
So, which is why I was very confused.
I was confused.
And the bright side, we might get hurt less.
What do you mean?
What do you mean some pie?
You should have just used scissors.
But it was a really cute fruit knife.
It was like, it was a cute color.
It was like this kind of like reddish,
orange fruit knife.
I got it at Ikea.
With scissors it's really easy to remember the sharp side, right?
Yeah, of course.
It's easy.
But I was unfamiliar with fruit knives game.
I can make cakes and stuff too,
but sometimes I spill a little bit of the flour,
or I accidentally put too much butter in.
Actually, the last time I made cookies,
actually not the first time I made cookies.
I wasn't cookies.
Sorry, it was bread.
First time I tried making bread.
So, first time I tried making bread,
I misread the...
I didn't realize there was a difference
between tablespoon and teaspoon.
So, when I asked for 3 teaspoons of salt,
I put in 3 tablespoons of salt.
And let me just say, not even the birds wanted it.
It's okay, I'll get better for you, Senpai.
I'll be a good wife, I promise.
I think mom was right, maybe just a little bit.
Well, she does have those memories fresh in her mind,
so that's why she's like,
if I go into the kitchen and I'm like,
I want to make this, she's like,
stop, I'll make it for you.
What do you mean you don't want to marry me?
What do you mean you don't want to marry me, Senpai?
Mazodia obliterate!
That was mean Senpai, you shouldn't say things like that.
He shouldn't say things like that.
I'm trying my best to be a good wife.
Anyways, let's continue.
Paul, what do you mean the Paul?
What Barber fully is, is his pride and joy.
Brought it all the way over from Italy.
Wrapped off special-like.
Wrapped off special-like?
It ain't no but colored glass,
with some bulbs just stuck up in it.
He thinks it's to be all in, doll.
Install that alarm system just to protect it.
Though who in Tarnation
would want to steal a worthless piece of junk like that?
I don't know.
Maybe them aliens, Clem.
Oh, the aliens?
Oh, Pete, don't be ignorant.
Aliens don't give a fig for no colored glass.
You think if they can build spaceships,
they can't make a bad-gum barber pole?
Well, maybe.
They don't know nothing about science.
Can we get a pole in the basement?
It'll be nice to watch when Kauai is in here.
But Senpai,
give you the television on all the time,
with all of my VHSs.
You can watch anything you want.
I highly recommend the Digimon the first movie.
We get a TV.
Yeah, very small one.
Everyone gets to watch it.
Can I watch Berserk?
Only the first one, okay?
Any following...
Any...
And definitely not the 3D one,
or the following ones, okay?
No!
Excuse me.
Pastirelli shelled out for an alarm system all right,
but he's too cheap to hire an electrician to hook her up.
Dang, Egypt cross-wired it through the fire sprinkler.
So now when the alarm goes off,
it sets the sprinkler spraying.
Coronation.
Aliens looking for intelligent life
ought to stay away from this shop, sure enough.
Hmm.
Is that the hint for the firefighters, perhaps?
Wait, do you actually like Digimon,
or was that a meme?
Every birthday senpai.
I rewatched the Digimon movie.
On the VHS it has the Angela Anaconda shorts in front of it.
Hmm, that one.
I watch the one that has like 3 movies attached into it.
I watch it for my birthday all the time.
Every year.
It's like tradition now.
And then, I don't know if all versions have this one,
but at the end they have kids of America music video,
like a flash music video.
Are you gonna watch it together?
I only have it on VHS, so I don't know.
I don't know if I...
I don't know how to share VHS.
Hmm, that's the one I have.
I also have like a variety of Pokemon movies too.
My first gift from Mama...
Well, first gift that I can remember from Mama and Papa
was Pokemon the first movie.
Well, let's talk about aliens.
Well, son, the ways of the alien is a specialized area of woodcraft,
the known to all but the wily of sportsmen.
What you gotta remember is your average alien is smarter than your average human,
so you gotta be extra careful building your blind if you want a bag one.
You hunt aliens?
Son, after nailing an alien, you can never go back to quails.
Nailing?
You can get one of those and just swap me.
Line your blind with lead to fool their sensing machines.
Lay real quiet and wait.
Preferably in the woods around the nuclear base.
Oh, they love messing around out there.
Why not wait outside your field, clan?
Wait for them to come a-carving.
Oh, they do their crop doodles with zap guns, you dirty fool.
Don't you know nothing?
There's no place to put the blind out in the field.
Now you listen to Clem Parsons if you want to tag in a nursery being.
They cross the void, wondering what lies beyond,
all the time not knowing if what awaits them is bookshot.
Do you guys remember when the U.S. government said aliens were real?
That was a few months ago, but everyone forgot that they said it before.
Like during COVID?
So I feel like everyone's like,
Aliens are real?
Didn't they say that already?
Oh, there's aliens.
And now I'm like, oh, okay.
They said it before, and then after that,
and then after that they announced it again,
and everyone's like, oh gosh, aliens.
And I'm like, no, I'm pretty sure they have announced this before.
I thought it was just UFOs the first time.
Isn't that still alien-ish?
Oh wow, I totally believe it.
I totally believe it, Senpai.
Why?
Because maybe we can get married in space.
We can get married in space.
I think that'll be nice.
Did we talk about Pastor Ali again?
Alarm system.
Okay, bye.
Okay, that's a good hint that the alarm system
is connected to the fire alarm.
So when that happens...
Let's go to the lodge first.
The heck is that?
Red eyes gleam with eerie malevolence from the darkness.
What the heck is that?
Your voice is really deep.
Your mind touched me, huh?
Your excitement warmed my attention.
Do you hunger for true knowledge?
Speaking of...
This is Steve's voice actor.
I can do this too.
Do you hunger for true knowledge?
Anyways, Senpai, did you know that I'm always touching you too?
Did you know that?
Because every time you hear my voice,
the bones in your ear is touching.
Which makes the vibrations for you to hear sound.
So therefore, I'm always touching you when you hear my voice.
Isn't that amazing?
Always think about that.
I'm always touching you, Senpai.
Anyways, yeah, I wanna join the lodge.
Okay.
Paper work? Okay, give me an application, then.
Well, I can't believe the lodge has bureaucracy.
Okay.
Fine, I'll get it.
Man, why do they always cemetery shady oaks?
Can I go down here? Fire station, police station.
Meat plant.
I'll stop this.
How'd I convince him?
Maybe I can get a clue.
Hmm.
What should I do?
Big sale, big sale.
Hmm.
It hasn't exactly said anything yet.
I don't think, yeah, I don't think I can convince him just yet.
Missile base.
Why is he doing yoga or does he have no legs?
Oddly enough, this guard booth is the only building in the base.
Section 21?
Okay.
Is there anyone being drafted right now?
Buster?
Pink?
What's wrong with pink? I love pink.
Wait, are we still in the Cold War?
Are we still in the Cold War?
Okay.
That's right.
Been in charge here since WW2.
But I got my lower torso showing up.
No, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're not doing yoga.
Those panty wastes in Washington wanted to stick me behind a desk.
To hell with that.
They owed me.
I left my legs in Dsseldorf.
Of course they felt that after the trauma of having to crawl from Germany to England,
trailing my intestines behind me.
It was too emotionally unstable to continue in the military.
Fair.
That's why they gave me this nice cushy job and put me in charge of the nuclear missiles.
Can I talk?
The button?
Why are you asking about the button, son?
I'm just a little nervous about it.
I mean, suppose an accident happens.
Don't get your panties in a bunch, mister.
The button is perfectly safe.
I keep it on my person all the time.
Is that a hint?
No commie bastard is getting his mitts on this button.
No, sorry, Bob.
No one initiates a nuclear holocaust and harvest except me.
Doesn't that make you feel better?
Yeah?
Harvest?
Harvest is a fine town.
Steeped in traditional American values.
But that lodge...
Well, it makes me suspicious.
Don't mind saying it.
They've got their fingers into everything around here.
Like a certain red commie bastard, Menace, which will be nameless.
Ow, stay away from the lodge.
You read me wrong, mister.
I think you should join the lodge, infiltrate it,
and report back on any red sympathizers.
Okay, I'll do that.
That would affect my decision on what I've got to do.
Okay, commie bastard.
Frankly, all these questions are making me a little suspicious of you.
Maybe you're one of those pink-blooded Americans.
What's pink-blooded?
Can you give me any reason why I shouldn't shoot you right now?
No, not really.
I appreciate your honesty, comrade.
Eh?
Okay.
What did I do?
I just caused nuclear!
I caused a holocaust?
What's pink anyways?
What about...?
They've got lower torso.
I think it was a slang for American with communist sympathies.
Okay!
It's okay.
Hi.
Okay.
Where's the exit?
Can I ask him some more questions?
Or is that it?
Does he give any necessary hints?
Okay, I'll ask some more.
Lamas?
Is that a yes or a no?
Uh...
What, Lamas?
No?
Okay.
I guess I gotta infiltrate the fire...
department.
Oh.
Fair.
Fair, fair.
Very fair.
Oh, art!
Ooh, doggy!
saliva is foaming from his...
from his barking chops.
Decorative Oriental fans from Ming Dynasty.
A picture of phallic-like structure standing in a roll.
Compressionist landscape.
Picture of a storybook fairy castle.
Don't bother me, I'm sketching.
Oh, look what you made me do!
Hello, Steve!
Welcome to the House of Flame, as we like to call it.
Oh, cut it out, Spots.
Honestly.
Once it gets barking, a good piece of meat
is the only way to shut him up.
There you go, Spots.
Aw.
It's nice to meet you, Sparky!
Oh my god, I just love your outfit!
I respect them.
Why did you hear about my memory loss?
Oh, another kidder, huh?
Such as...
Such as?
Mom, huh?
That sounds fantastic!
Don't be such a party group, Steve.
We're talking about art.
We're talking about art here, okay?
We haven't had a flowery heart
since the newspaper building burned down.
So I'll admit that the wasp woman's place
is one big accident waiting to happen.
Isn't that right, Spots?
Uh-huh, uh-huh, yeah.
Yeah, that place is a safety hazard.
Oh well, let's talk about art.
Love art.
It does!
Provocative, you say?
You're right, it is beneath me.
Hey, newspaper fire.
A dreadful affair.
You wouldn't think that a brick-and-steel building
with a sprinkler system could go up that quickly.
You're right.
You think it was arson?
Oh, please.
Dwayne was glad enough.
You're right.
Please.
Dwayne was glad enough to see the thing go up.
And so was McKnight.
If you could get into that safe in his wall...
Oh, get it.
I know.
As far as I know, the fire was an accident.
Let's just leave it at that.
So it wasn't an accident.
How don't you go moving?
Hey, wasp woman?
Some people think all we do is sit around
sketching betting examples of manhood for our own amusement.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
Why, just the other day,
we decided to take a crumb for firecoat violations.
All the dried-up paper-walked nests
clustered around our wooden house.
Why, it's a kenlog just waiting for the right faggot.
Ah!
Believe me, none of us wants to see another fiasco
like the Sentinel fire.
Bye-bye.
Can't talk now, Steve, I'm inspired.
I don't converse on the job, Steve.
YouTube!
YouTube, this is a part of the game.
It's just a different time.
We understand respectfully that this,
that, that, um,
that these are outdated terms.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Can't talk now.
Bye-bye.
I don't con-
Stop it, you're messing me up!
Wait, is there a fireplace in there?
Actually, just waiting to happen.
I like that the fire thingy is pink.
Oh, wait, wait, no, I can ask about communism, right?
Can't talk now, Steve.
Communism, do I spell it right?
Come again?
Are you, uh...
Pink?
Come again?
L-la-launch?
Okay, bye.
Bye-bye.
I guess that's fine.
Newspaper building.
What's left at the newspaper building after an extreme fire?
Chevrolet's sticking out of the building's ashes.
Can I grab it?
I want it, I want it!
Yeah.
At least the plumbing held up.
That's good plumbing.
What about police station?
The cop ignores you, you're too busy writing a bug report.
The pot hisses at you from its perch.
Hmm, a map of harvest.
Hello, Steve. Let me introduce myself.
I'm Sheriff Dwayne Dwayne.
D-Dwayne Dwayne, huh?
Pleasure, I reckon.
Then, we haven't met before?
Of course we have.
But I heard about your alleged amnesia and figured I'd play along.
I sure hope this is just a prank.
And not the start of some insanity play.
Keep your nose clean or you'll wind up in jail.
And that's no place to hold a wedding.
Alright, amnesia.
Why do you want to break your poor mama's heart with all this amnesia bug?
I'm telling you the truth.
Oh geez, Steve, calm down.
You've always been a kidder, Steve.
Kidder count!
Boy, you need to stop all this funning and get serious.
You've got a wedding coming up soon.
Heck, you should be thinking about your career
and about joining the lodge.
Wedding.
Amnesia or no.
You can't have forgotten you're about to marry the prettiest little thing at harvest.
I think you and Stephanie are perfect for each other.
I just hope her father's disappointment doesn't spoil everything.
Disappointment?
Mr. Potsdam wants to hold the wedding in the lodge.
But he'll never get in.
Like all the rest, he's always hanging around the post office the first day of the month.
Waiting for Boyle to bring out that much lodge applications.
There's always a long line.
Never enough applications to go around.
And even if you do get an application, chances are you're right out of luck.
If you recall to the order and even less accepted.
And Potsdam?
Well, they've turned him down so many times.
Unless he does something radical, he'll never get in.
Okay, let's check crime.
Crime wise, nothing much has happened in harvest since the newspaper fire.
Oh, sure.
Every week or so, we get the odd transient dropping dead.
But other than that, it gets...
Every old, huh?
Pertiest!
Good night and got a road trip tomorrow.
Need some sleep.
Good night.
Good luck on your road trip.
I don't remember anything.
Kitter count.
Who's the perp?
We found the gas can that was used.
Yes, sorry, Bob.
It's in the evidence room.
That's classified, darn it.
How many times are you gonna have to tell me to keep my mouth shut?
I wonder.
Sorry, boss.
It's okay there, partner.
Who can make out all those curvy lines anyhow?
No, it's sitting in there gathering dust.
Clean is the day we found it.
Just in case I ever need a spare gas can.
Huh, okay, they don't do their job well.
I'm sorry, let me try that again.
Ah, chocks.
They don't do their job well.
Dang it, and tell me about my amnesia.
Why do you want to break your poor mama's heart with all this amnesia bunk?
I'm telling you the truth.
Okay, got it.
Yeah.
Boy, you need to stop all.
Why about my win?
You can't have forgotten you're about to marry the prettiest little thing.
Right.
Mr. Potts.
What about the Lodge?
I don't mind telling you.
I'd never get anything done if not for the Lodge's efforts.
To join the order of the harvest moon is the highest dream of everyone in harvest.
I'm gonna get an application.
And like I said, unless you get an application on the first day of the month, you're generally out of luck.
Okay, bye.
Stop on by any time, Steve.
Can I go into the evidence room?
Door is locked.
That's the evidence room.
Where we store items lifted from crime scenes.
It's kept locked at all times.
There's things in there that could make people jump through hoops, if I wanted.
Oh, you're not only lazy here, but you're also corrupt.
Solve cases.
Unsolved.
Unsolved arson.
Anything I can help you with?
That coffee smells good.
Step yourself.
Speaking of which, you're real lucky to be marrying Stephanie.
She don't look like a good woman.
I just hope she don't turn out like Mrs. Loomis.
What do you mean she don't look like a good woman?
Mercy?
Mercy mentioned?
Hard on a man's needs, don't you know?
Stephanie?
Oh, gosh darn, she's pretty.
Kind of like a gal I seen on some of their French postcards they used to make.
Used to be.
I take them things, go back in the jail.
There's nobody was there and kind of look them over one handed.
Hold some towels.
That was the four Mrs. Loomis.
Huh?
Oh, gosh, I wish I had some of them girly pictures.
But Mrs. Loomis won't let me keep them in the house.
I still remember the time she caught me holding some of them pictures up with one hand.
She took the broom to me.
I held like a hound dog.
The broom going up and down.
What?
I was crawling blood, blood and straw.
And I brooked.
I was crying so bad.
And it was so hard I had to crawl under the porch naked.
With all the black winter spiders and I got bit something fierce.
Little things are digging into my bare behind all over.
I ask you, is that any way to treat a man?
And Mrs. Phelps and the sheriff don't make it no easier neither.
Where did that broom go?
What did he mean?
Up and down?
Where did it go?
Oh, wait.
You're right.
He's cheating.
No, he deserved that.
You're right.
He is a cheater.
We don't like, we don't like his kind.
Mrs. Phelps down at the general store don't help things, none.
She's got them special picture books.
The one with the ladies.
But she won't sell me none on account of she knows my wife, Mrs. Loomis.
That gum that don't burn my bridges.
If I even ask about them, she tells Mrs. Loomis and I get the broom.
Enough to break a man's heart.
Her burning my French postcards.
We unable to replace them.
We don't like cheaters.
You have a wonderful wife.
Man's need.
Why, you sure ought to appreciate what a man's got to do sometimes in a parked car
or waste hide not hole in a tree.
A what?
A tree?
Matter of fact, Mrs. Phelps got no reason not to sell you some of them French postcard
girly picture books.
If you can get any, it's the clear the park with them.
The sheriff's at lunch and I'd be obliged.
French postcards.
Of course.
I don't necessarily mean French postcards.
Oh.
That's just what we called them in my day.
In a kind of girly picture book, the kind men like would be just dandy.
I'd be right right, kiddo, if you were to bring me one.
That's the hint.
Got it.
Okay.
What if I say fuck?
Don't know what you mean, kiddo.
Broom?
Don't know.
Okay, never mind.
Bye.
Anytime, kiddo.
Oh, let's go to diner.
1955 frag 100 with a real leather leather seat.
Even from the ground, you can hear this sonorous, sonorous, sonorous buzz of neon.
Oh, wait, the sheriff's here.
Hi.
What's your name?
Karen.
What are you doing?
Playing.
My mom is working, so I gotta stutter her hair.
Wanna play?
Not now, maybe later.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Oh.
Why is she the normal one?
So nice, so no.
Can we get a picture book for the cage?
Oh, you want some pretty French postcards for the cage?
But be a lower one.
Maybe.
But then Senpai, you're mine.
Dude, you only want pretty pictures of me, right?
Just me.
Good.
A coloring book?
You want pencil crayons or crayon crayon?
Oh, I'm afraid to give my Senpai's crayons though, but you might eat it.
You might eat it, just like glue.
I knew you would, I knew you would do that, so no coloring books for my Senpai's.
None, none, none, none.
Oh, she has a nice voice.
You know me?
I guess I've changed.
I'm not kidding.
Cheebie!
And me!
And me and Cheebie!
Welcome to the stream!
My girls are here.
Shut the fuck up!
My girls are here!
I'm so happy!
Wow, how was, how was Call of the Lamb?
How was Call of the Lamb?
I can't tell, but in me ready to, I didn't see a message.
Alright, it's in me just here watching me.
Oh, if it's in me just here watching me, I'll be, I'll be a good, I'll be a good.
She streamed for like nine hours.
Trying to, trying to catch up with Mame.
Just watching Cheebie.
Make sense, make sense.
Hello and good night.
Enjoy Harvester.
It's such a silly game.
Oh, thank you, Cheebie.
I didn't read, I just came out from Cheebie's stream.
That's no problem.
Thank you.
Thank you, girlies.
The two, two, two blonde girlies.
Ten.
Oh, yeah.
Like Mame, like daughter.
I think, I think we all take a bit of Mame's, Mame's aspects.
I think we, I think we do.
Good night, Cheebie.
Talk to you in.
What, did you inherit Mercy?
They can't, you know, burps.
Occasionally.
I don't think I have done it yet, but sometimes I do.
Good night.
I'll always say excuse me though.
What else did I inherit?
I'll have to ask Mame.
A shark, what?
Do you think I'm pretty shark?
Well, of course I am.
Look at these scissors.
I don't burp as much as Emi or Mame though.
I think I heard Emi say that she can do it on command, and that's really, that's really amazing.
That's really amazing.
Me on the other hand, I can't do it on command.
Anytime that happens, it'll be, it'll be by accident.
It's not hard to burp.
It's kind of hard for me.
I don't like, I can't, like, whistling and can't do it.
I can't do it.
Well, everyone can burp on command?
Am I the only one left out?
Could I compete for number one against Mame?
You might be able to, Emi.
I probably can't.
Sometimes mine accidentally gets really loud, but I think it's because when I drink water, the air gets stuck because my uvula is kind of enlarged so it might get caught behind it.
That's, that's Ethereum, not quite sure.
And then I let out a big one, but I don't think it's a record, but I haven't yet.
I sneeze a lot more than I burp though.
I never realized it, but after like seeing my, one time seeing my sneeze together, I was like, oh, I sneeze the same way over and over.
You breathe in while lifting your palate or something until you hear a little pop and you exhale and burp.
I think I just feel coffee from that.
Hey, Karen.
You've met Karen, my eight year old.
Oh, she's so cute.
Other than the diner, she's all I have.
Oh!
No, something bad's gonna happen, I feel it.
Ah!
Hey, Kohai, what's the tea of the day?
Orange ginger.
Yeah, I don't think I don't want to burp.
Thank you.
Let's not burp right now.
I don't want to force it.
I might get sick.
I feel a little sick probably because I've been a little unwell, probably because I've kind of overworked myself.
This is an entirely full week.
I'm actually probably, I'm thinking I might move a few weeks.
Wait, I might feel a burp.
Is it working?
No, nothing.
But yeah, I'm a little sick because I think I've overworked myself a little bit.
Because I might lower my schedule for next week because I really need a big break, at least a day of rest.
Because even when I'm off streaming, I still have to keep up that social media presence as well.
And then I have to think of things and events to do.
And then I have to work on my audios and then additional videos if possible.
So it doesn't sound like a lot, but it takes a lot of time for all of them.
And it takes a lot of energy.
It could be due to stress too.
I should probably rest up a little more.
But I want this tomorrow is the last day of the full week.
So hopefully I can find some way to slow down a little bit.
So yeah, everyone can see all types of games that I play.
Wait, did I talk about Stephanie already?
There isn't a nicer girl in Harvest than Stephanie, Steve.
You should be grateful that she's promised you her hand.
I don't remember that happening, Edna.
Honestly, you men are so childish.
I don't know what it is about marriage that turns even the bravest man into a coward.
I was going to marry Karen's father when he just up and ran out on me one night.
We hate him.
I heard that he joined the lodge.
But if he did, I never saw him come out again.
Even Sheriff Dwayne wasn't able to find out what happened to him.
Mr. Johnson has a liking for me.
I call it a crush, but that's too innocent a word.
He's a bitter man with too much time on his hands.
He's never gotten over being rejected by the lodge.
And there's something unwholesome in the way he looks at me.
I'm always glad when the sheriff comes in every day at noon.
The lodge is the repository of all wisdom.
You should join the order of the Harvest Moon, Steve.
And soon.
Why?
I'd say, what is it about this place?
The wheat ripens and waits not for the sigh.
The farmer who waits too long.
Wait.
He used the sigh to rip his own stomach out then to stay his side when the wheat ripens.
The Harvest Moon wanes and then comes winter.
An empty belly.
The body stands.
The body stands, belly.
Lurgling within or bloody on the ground.
What does it benefit a man if he gains his soul and loses the world?
You hunger.
Feed yourself.
Before it's too late.
Late.
Oh.
What's wrong?
Steve.
Well, what happened?
Were we talking about Boyle?
Or was it Karen?
You seem strange there for a minute.
I'm sorry.
I'm under a lot of stress.
Running this diner all alone.
Forgive me.
You've met Karen.
Bye.
Stop by anytime, Steve.
Hello there, Steve.
Here for lunch?
Yep.
No.
Just here looking around.
Well, I'm not entirely sure where here is.
She's under a lot of stress, Boyle.
You need a break before you start speaking in tongues.
Well, Boyle, this is DNA's diner.
Isn't that right, Edna?
Don't listen to Sheriff Dwayne.
This is Edna's diner.
But ever since the E burned out on the sign,
they've been giving me a hard time.
Now, don't be like that, Edna.
It's a great place to eat, which is good.
Since it's the only place to eat in harvest.
Bye.
Stop on by anytime, Steve.
Oh, how do I exit?
Oh, here it is.
Oh, wait.
Is there anything else I should look at?
Well, the diner people seem nice.
Oh, wrong place.
I meant to go to the thing.
Is he still at the police station?
Hold on.
Just in case.
Here's your girly magazine.
Oh, oh, by George.
Oh, by Jiminy.
Oh, can I have it?
Yeah.
Oh, thank you, Steve.
Excuse me, kiddo.
I've got to go check the jail for clean towels.
Oh, yeah.
Now the evidence room is mine.
Never mind.
This fairly legible note.
Checkbook.
Give me the key.
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to click that exit.
Give me the stuff.
A berry.
Arbus brand, old brand of smokes.
Where is it?
Beer.
There it is.
Anything else?
I didn't work like that, too.
Is there anything else?
Is there anything else in here?
Take the shoes.
The bear?
Bear is wielding a chainsaw.
What's with all these models?
There's another woman's body.
Oh, I'm surprised.
Loomis has painted this evidence.
Bottom right here.
Hello, Steve.
Where's Loomis?
Loomis, have you?
No.
Did I fuck up?
Okay, I can go back in again.
Is there anything else I can grab?
Loomis's light relatives.
Prop helps the sheriff meet a ticket quota.
Is there anything else in here?
Okay, if there's nothing else, let's get out of here.
Door's locked.
TV station.
Sorry, I meant to go to Edna's diner.
Oh, he's back here again, okay.
Okay, bye.
Okay, let's do...
Let's go to the TV station.
Let's go to the game.
As long as we don't fuck up.
Oh, I should have just saved into a different one.
Too busy drinking and smoking, they ignore you.
Oh, they found it here.
Steve.
Yeah.
Yeah, yes.
Oh, TV violence.
I love all the blood and gore on your show.
Here's the commentary.
Just look at the net profits.
Huh?
Very poor reception is strange since the broadcast originates from here.
A picture of a gorgeous model signed with a kiss my pineapple.
Red and muffy.
An assortment of empty cubicles, either McKnight loves to recall his salad days as an insurance salesman.
You can't keep up with him, or you can't keep his employees happy.
Hey, Sport, this is a private office.
Yeah, I know, Mr. McKnight.
I own and operate this station.
Have you brought me some news for the night broadcast, or...
I've lost my memory.
That's news.
The hell it is.
You always were a kid, or Steve.
Any real news to tell me?
Actually, I was just wanting to know more about the TV station.
Huh.
Hey, W-H-A-R is the only television station in Harvest.
Since the old Sentinel went under, what with the newspaper building burning down and all?
We're golden.
Nobody competes with us, Sport.
Did you burn it down?
On Quincet.
Hey, now, Sport, that's an irresponsible allegation.
I had nothing to do with that fire.
Just because W-H-A-R may have benefited from it, and I danced on the ashes a little, doesn't mean...
A little?
You can share it the way, and give me doubts.
You seem awfully touchy on the subject, Sport.
I'm touchy when people try to muscle their way into my business.
I'd appreciate it if you'd leave my office, and don't come back.
No.
Don't hurry back.
What about the villains?
Oh, okay.
What's the first choice?
Whoa!
Godless heathen engines.
Most kids don't see godless heathen engines on a regular basis,
and if they do, they'd better either get their eyes checked,
or do like old range rider, and shoot the bejesus out of them.
Lest they want to go untreated for psychotic hallucinations,
or wind up with their scalps hanging from a buckskin...
YouTube!
Shit!
Ow!
Shit on a sticker room!
YouTube, this is part of game!
The parents that are griping about violence on TV
are the same parents that go outside in the morning to fetch their papers,
secure in the knowledge that they won't get an arrow through the noodle,
because the violence they hate so much done cleared the engines out of the neighborhood.
Yeah, civilization has benefited from violence.
But should violence be treated as entertainment?
Check my rating, son.
Violence is entertainment.
I just put it on the air.
That says something about the kid, not me.
Now, excuse me, we're going back on the air.
Alright.
Aw, no one's operating the camera.
A corny western backdrop complete with a cardboard teepee.
Hmm.
Either the show isn't compelling,
or no one wanted to be taken out by friendly...
by friendly fire.
A fairly primitive form of mind control.
We can exit this way.
The meat plant.
We should save.
I don't know, it seems dangerous to go to a meat plant.
What's with... what is that? Are these cats?
Cats?
Is that a bone?
Steve, I didn't want to believe that amnesia hook'em.
Now you're saying you don't remember your pal, Pat O'Reilly?
Pat O'Reilly, huh?
Oh, let's talk about the family business, I guess.
Why are they in the meat plant?
Because daddy owns the meat plant.
You may come to realize that this business is not for everybody.
Just ask your poor, ill dad.
It takes dedication and a strong stomach.
A lot of times, when I'm finished scrubbing up
and digging the bits of intestine out from my fingernails,
I must confess, I don't have much appetite for red meat.
But red meat is one of the principal food groups,
and you've got to have it.
So when you can do this all day,
and help yourself to a juicy red steak afterwards,
then by golly, you can call yourself a butcher.
Alright!
Of course, amnesia would certainly help that, wouldn't it?
Dad's on this.
Does everyone want to get me into lodge?
Amnesia?
Kitter count.
You're gonna need to start behaving like an adult,
especially if you're gonna take over the family business.
Family business?
Meat?
Where do you keep the animals?
Does it matter?
The end product is all the customer cares about, Steve.
And we only carry the finest meat,
only the juiciest cuts.
What do you use?
Once you take over the business,
you'll realize the importance of maintaining quality
while cutting costs.
We know what we're doing.
We didn't.
Would the lodge use us to cater their affairs?
Good. Could I take some meat to take home?
Okay, here's a hint.
Cutting costs.
If you're cutting up the meat, you'll be privy to them.
There's always cheaper, better ways to do things.
If you're creative.
If you're creative?
Family business?
Goodbye!
That's nice, I guess.
There are several small animals.
This used to be a kitty cat.
Okay, we're eating!
The plant's eating!
Cats understood.
Is there anything else in here?
Okay, I need a written note.
Let me go back to my house.
What do I have?
Got a pen, newspaper,
aspirin,
off-medicine,
vitamins, tampons.
What do I have?
I got a pen, newspaper,
aspirin,
off-medicine, vitamins,
tampons,
jar of oralu,
shovel,
bloody sneakers,
gas can,
camera,
checkbook.
What does it say? I can't fucking see!
Deposit boil,
deposit boil, deposit boil,
check,
boil,
deposit,
boil, tulip ammunition,
one crate of shells.
Oh, it is the war, guys, huh?
No, right-click to view.
Sheriff, if you think...
I'm going to keep paying this...
forever.
You are crazy. There are limits.
Boil.
Who's Boil again?
Can I use this?
Meet permission sleep.
Okay.
We're saving.
Check out the windows.
Like at my house?
I need...
It says fill up head screws.
I don't have screw.
I don't have a screw unless I use
like something irrational,
like a shovel.
Damn it.
See?
It'd be hilarious if it worked.
Yeah.
I don't have a knife.
What does this mean?
No...
Why...
Is the Sheriff blackmailing you?
That's an interesting item.
But the fact that you asked me that question
proves you know nothing.
I can show these around
and prove both of you
are guilty of something.
You do that, Steve.
Not knowing what we're guilty of,
how much trouble can you cause?
Except for yourself.
Oh, yeah?
I want to do it again.
What does this mean?
I know why the Sheriff
is blackmailing you.
This is unexpected
and awkward.
But my luck's been bad ever since Dwayne
found that darn gas can at the newspaper
building the day after the fire.
He has this insane notion that it's mine.
I pay him not
because I'm guilty, but because I don't want
him slurring my good name around harvest.
Oh, naturally.
You know, he keeps that gas can
in the evidence room at his office.
I'd be really grateful
to whoever could fetch me that can.
Grateful enough
to provide him with a lodge application.
Oh, and Steve,
you'll keep this to yourself
if you're smart.
I can trade it,
but I want to see what the fingerprints do.
Or I don't even have that.
Can I figure out if he did it or not?
I'm going to do it anyways.
Against my better judgment,
what do you think, Senpai?
We give it...
Yes.
You know, this morning
as I was making my rounds,
I noticed an awful lot of television
aerials on the roofs.
Seems like more and more each day.
You got me this can
just in time, youngster.
I may have need of it again.
What do you mean?
There's another reason why Sheriff Dwayne
didn't investigate the Sentinel fire.
If you'd like to get something else
on the black mailing bastard, check around
the television station.
Why do you still can?
Okay.
Did I get a launch application thing?
Can I use the pen on it?
That's a ticket.
Can I give this to my brother?
Okay.
I hope you understand what he means.
As in like the...
The place is going to go down in flames?
Should I...
Is there anything at the station
that I need or that I missed?
Yes?
There's an off-shelf thing in the back.
Okay.
Nothing.
What is...
Where can I get the...
Get it.
Okay.
Oops.
No, no, no.
Go back.
How do I get the number?
This is your first arrest, Steve.
You just remember.
We've got three strikes.
You're out rule here in harvest.
But you keep your nose clean.
You're here.
So I didn't get arrested?
Oh, good kiss, good night.
And I got tucked in. That's nice.
Okay.
You're in trouble.
How does it feel to be a jailbird?
I think it makes you miss out on stuff though.
Okay, I'll just...
Yeah.
What are you yet?
You better not get caught against, Steve.
You played your get-out jail-free card.
Next time, you'll be in...
Does that make me miss things?
I can just load the game again.
Hmm.
I'm a mar...
I'm a mario school.
Hmm.
Quality time.
Quality time?
I don't know.
Who's first name escapes me?
I hear there's an honorary plaque
commemorating him
within the lodge.
Lodge?
Big guy.
Boring some quality time.
The greatest gift I can bestow upon you
as your former principal
is a word of advice.
Join the order
of the harvest moon at any cost.
Within the lodge
lies your future.
And without
dust.
Why do you keep calling me big guy?
They sign of respect, lad.
As principal, my station is higher
than yours now.
But you never know what the future holds.
So you should always hedge your bets
and pay tribute
to your inferiors.
You know who will come to power.
Inferiors? Oh.
Even now, wheels sit behind the scenes.
For all I know, you might already be a member
of the order with access
to the lodge.
If that were the case, you'd be my superior
and I'd be all that much better off
having shown you respect
and spent some quality
time with you.
Quality time?
Myself, I tip a discipline
with love.
Oh, love!
Love can be such a warm
sharing experience.
After just a few sessions,
you'd stop this amnesia nonsense
and become a productive
member of society.
Oh, love!
Okay.
Big guy,
boring some quality time.
Drop in again soon.
Adult education is
a wonderful thing
as is adult quality
time.
I want some quality time.
Last protected fire alarm.
Will not let you use
the fire alarm.
Drinking fountain doesn't work.
These lockers are riddled with inexplicable
stains and dent.
Door is locked.
Uh-huh.
The children look stunned and zombified.
Even the paper cutouts look stunned
and zombified.
Oh, I don't need to go back in.
My goodness.
Class, this is Steven.
He used to be a student
here at Gean Memorial.
Say hello, class.
They're reticent.
The educator's greatest problem
today is the apathy of the students.
What's wrong with there?
It.
I can tell you in one word, Steven.
Discipline.
Goodness, you weren't a sulky bear.
You were always a smiley bear.
Then...
You remember me?
Not as such.
So many pupils, Steven.
They come and they go.
But I can always spot those who are nice boys.
You can tell from the forehead.
The lobes, right, class?
I'm glad you stopped by, Steven.
Would you care to say a few words to the class
about civic responsibility?
Not really.
I was just passing through.
But you must, Steven.
A positive role model might be just the thing
to inspire these little monsters.
Steven, have you any questions for me?
Or shall I continue with class?
Yes, I do.
Harvest.
You tell me anything about the harvest.
Harvest was founded by the order
of the Harvest Moon about 100 years ago.
For what purpose?
Why, I'm sure you'd have to ask them.
You'll find the members of the order at the lodge.
Dang!
Uh...
Lodge.
Why is everyone so...
Okay!
And at some point, should I wait?
A baseball bat!
If an A-bomb hits,
what good is it going to do
to duck and cover?
Okay, that's fine.
Is this why...
Yeah, is this why we had memory loss?
I was like, oh, this is fine!
And then I saw the blood and I was like,
this is not fine anymore.
Don't buy any time, Steven.
Okay.
So you don't get to look
at what the kids look like? Okay.
Okay.
Where else did I not go yet?
Shad's...
Shady, sorry.
I was reading it wrong.
Shady...
I was reading it wrong. Shady...
Memorial?
Those volts of candles
have been lit by many well-wishers
for the dead or well-wishers
with a lot of matches.
Those geared to us
who have passed recently.
Jonathan A. Reigncliff.
Kedro for this week's funerary event.
I mean, this is an okay place
to have the wedding.
Oh!
It counters this new tube of astraglue.
I wanted it.
Security.
Like what? Money?
I'm afraid that's not good enough.
I need that glue for my work.
You must present me with something
significant if you'd have me
part with it.
Like tampons?
I am Daniel Moynihan.
Mortician and proprietor
of the wayward hotel.
Most people ask me why I don't
remember their names.
Well, you always were a kidder.
Another kidder!
What losses?
Ah, not the PTA.
Okay, that sounds suspicious.
Okay.
Oh, Order of the Harvest Moon?
You're a part of it, isn't it?
Mm-hmm.
Thank you, Cole. Hi for housing us in the basement.
Do they work at the meat plant?
I always said small animals, right?
Yeah.
When they ran out of cats.
There was a lot of cats there.
A bake sale?
Oh wait, I already said that.
Losses?
The dead?
That's why I put some supplies in barrels.
Wayward Hotel.
I do my best to accommodate any hobo
who straggles into town vacancies permitting.
Very charitable of you.
Thank you.
Can I talk about the Wayward Hotel again?
Are the guys who dropped dead staying at your hotel?
I can't remember every little
Is he lying?
Why is everyone saying juicy?
Bye.
I look
Very nasty-looking sink.
The fan-wearing blades barely stir the stench-laden air.
The needle lies on 33 degrees Fahrenheit.
This membered organ,
which was never meant to pump a meldehyde.
Is there anything else in here?
Alright, this isn't salty at all.
A lectern for a priest.
A hauntingly beautiful stained glass window
in which a man holds a scythe
in one hand and some ethereal power in the other.
A saint kneels before a shepherd.
You jubilantly terrified.
Is there like a secret thing here?
We are in a cult
and it's probably run by
evil people.
Cemetery.
I guess we go in.
The headstone of this grave
site reads Jonathan
Jonathan A. Ryan Co-
Let's save.
Here lies Boxcar Willie.
Air reeks of fresh soil manure.
Two years in harvest was
Two years in harvest was too long.
Fear not in death.
Montages.
Scripture in the headstone has faded.
November 27th, 1948.
Another unknown visitor.
This tombstone is unmarked.
You don't know how to use a shovel.
Another resting place amongst
the graves.
What's here?
Marvel store have been sealed shut.
I don't know.
Wrong grave?
Well, that didn't work.
Okay.
Never mind then.
Is there anything else?
Maybe the diner?
Anything in the diner?
Oh, it's just me, right?
And
does not let her customers
behind the counter.
Bye, bye.
Okay, that's a little eerie.
Mr. Johnson's house.
Johnson?
Oh, right here.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Kidder count.
Okay, Edna.
What?
She needs a good, hard pain.
I can see why she doesn't like you.
I see why she doesn't like you.
You're not in this for love.
You're in this for other things.
How dare you?
I...
No, he's not in this for love.
I can tell.
After all, some pies are here because they're in love, right?
Well, tell me more about the diner.
Okay.
Okay, a little bit of whiplash there.
That's a little bit of whiplash there.
How Stephanie?
Oh, yeah, she's fine.
Can't we want both things?
Of course we can want both things.
But you have to want both things.
You can't just have...
the other thing.
Because without love, it's meaningless, right?
Speaking of Stephanie,
I still haven't gotten an invitation to the wedding yet.
I don't have anything to do with that.
That's okay.
Personally, I'd prefer a pass to the honeymoon.
A pass?
I could use the backseat of my tucker for the
maiden voyage.
It's plenty big.
Believe you me.
I'd drive you around.
And I wouldn't look in the backseat.
I guarantee it.
Though, if you'd like to come up front
and take the wheel a while,
I wouldn't say name.
Mimosa!
Also, this man is not allowed
at our honeymoon!
Mimosa!
Welcome to the stream!
Welcome!
No, but no.
I don't want anyone at our honeymoon Senpai.
Our honeymoon is very lovely
and romantic, okay?
This...
That is not romantic!
Mimosa, welcome to the stream!
Welcome!
Hello, Raiders!
My name is
Mercy Modis
from Gen 1...
No, from
Viewers! Gen 1
Indulge! Welcome!
Right now, we are playing!
I'm sorry.
I blanked out on the name for a second.
Welcome, Mimosa!
How was the stream?
What were you playing?
Sorry, I totally forgot.
I blanked out on the name.
No, I don't want to be...
Our honeymoon can't be here!
I remember playing that game.
I remember playing
Bunny Garden. It was real...
It was real fun. Did you like it?
Are you liking it?
I forgot the order
which I had to do it.
Welcome, welcome! There might be some
such things in this game, so
if you're not into the such stuff
maybe close your ears.
Thank you, Mimosa!
I hope you had a good one. Are you heading to bed?
I saw a girl with green lace panties.
It was amazing.
Wait, I played a different Bunny Game!
Bunny Garden Game!
This one's the new one!
With the Bunny! Bunny Girls!
Real Bunny Girls!
Not anthropomorphic
Bunny Girls!
Like, you know...
Sexy Bunny Girls!
Huh?
Right? This one's the sexy one!
And you can gamble!
Right? This is the new one, right?
This is the one.
The other one's like Bunny Bunny!
Am I...
I thought it was Bunny Garden.
Was it called something else?
No, no, no!
Uh...
Give me a second. Bunny Garden...
Sorry, I mistaken the name!
Sorry, sorry, sorry! I mistaken the name!
The game I was playing was called
the Bunny Graveyard!
There was a bit of gardening in it!
Ha ha ha ha!
There's a different location!
We did garden!
We did garden in there!
Graveyard Garden!
Same difference! They have dirt in them!
You know?
The same!
You still talked about sexy anthropomorphic bunnies!
Oh, no, no, no!
I meant like this one is anthropomorphic bunnies!
Bunny Garden, the other one,
is sexy bunnies!
Like Playboy bunnies!
But we don't say Playboy because we can get sued!
Ha ha ha ha!
But nice! Green panties!
I don't even think I have green panties!
What color are my panties?
No, they're bears! I forgot!
Yeah, they're bears! Ha ha ha ha ha!
Mercy, you kill me!
No...
Because Mimosa...
You slay!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ah!
Look at me! Look at me, senpais!
I have ribs!
Right? I have ribs!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay...
Don't...
Don't point out how long I've been wearing the same panties
for a doll!
Why are you keeping track anyways, huh?
We're gonna...
Shut up!
Yeah, I got the ribs!
So now...
Clearly!
Clearly, Mimosa
wants to be my best friend forever, right?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Well, you did say you hadn't
showered in days openly.
Well, my water's not exactly
in...
proper condition.
And it was just yesterday!
I showered yesterday! It's fine!
I think...
Actually...
Call me!
Mimosa!
You can slide into my DMs
anytime, don't worry.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Listen, girls!
The... the corporal girls, they don't...
They don't have...
They don't get to go in the cage. They have...
free access.
Oh, they don't have to stay.
They can stay if they want.
They have free access to come and go as they please.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I can't believe there is work.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Discrimination!
Don't get me wrong, Senpai!
Don't get me wrong!
It's not like I don't trust you,
but there's many times
in which I question the validity
of your words.
So that's why sometimes
the girls help me.
And then they help me clean up as well.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Remember
when you didn't put
my Oshi mark in your name, Senpai?
Remember when you said
that you didn't love me?
There's so many moments like that,
and I always give second chances.
More than checking chances.
At this point, it seems to be like
my endless amount of chances.
I'm so nice!
And all this time,
what do I get?
Not even my Oshi mark in your name.
I am so nice.
I give you a television in your cage.
I give you one happy meal
to share with everyone.
I give you five minutes of free time
so you even get to have some
some fun in there.
Come on!
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
So, Senpai's.
Senpai, Senpai's.
Now that you have it,
you have to earn my trust again.
You have to earn my trust again.
Because if I see you next day
without my Oshi mark,
we're going to have a lot of serious talking.
And by serious talking, I mean
perhaps talking where
you are met by the end of a shovel.
The spade side.
All right.
So that's all.
No ifs, and buts, and besides.
Besides.
The girls know how to keep a secret.
And, okay.
And, and
the cage
and the basement is my place
and your place, okay?
It's our private sanctuary.
I mean we'll also come for visits of course
but otherwise, it's our private sanctuary.
All right.
Okay.
It's our private sanctuary.
Although if mimosa wants to be called Senpai
then you know
she would have
to share the McDonald's meal too.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And then we'll have a wedding all together!
Hahahahaha!
No!
Then special privileges it is.
It's tomorrow Happy Meal Day or Monday.
It's once a month and I've already given the Happy Meal.
Anyways, let's continue on this.
I don't want to know but we're going to ask about Tucker.
Heck of an automobile, isn't she?
Damn shame I have to sit out here and watch over her all the time.
But if I didn't, those stupid kids might scratch her up playing ball.
Can I take a look at it?
A few months back someone broke into my house, trying to get into the garage.
I had to gripe my car before the sheriff agreed to start the evening patrols and instigate the curfew.
Only 51 cars were made, including their prototype, before the company was forced to declare bankruptcy and cease all operations on March 3, 1949 due to negative publicity initiated by the news media.
Let's see.
A Securities Exchange Commission investigation heavily publicized stock fraud trial in which the allegations for proven baseless and led to full acquittal.
Tucker suspected that big three automakers, Mexican Senator Homer S. Ferguson had a role in the Tucker corporation's demise.
So what, they didn't like the car or something?
Alright, okay, so I guess this car is really rare and that's why it's expensive? Okay.
I mean, that's why he cares about it so much, got it.
Why now?
During the day, Mr. Johnson keeps watch over his precious 48 Tucker.
Sorry, Steve. Too tired to talk right now. I just gave the Tucker a tune up. I'll talk to you later.
Okay, bye.
Okay, so this is an expensive car.
Or, well, a car that's very...
Am I missing something?
Where do I get a screwdriver, some pie?
Pie.
It's during the day he sits out there, but when he goes to the diner, is the car, you know, car?
A screwdriver store, shut up.
Does my house have one?
I won't be able to get the screwdriver today or tomorrow.
But why not?
Why not?
You want this autograph?
Actually, never mind. You're a brat.
You're a brat.
Big whoopsie.
Never mind.
I guess?
Yeah, me didn't fucking care.
Did I write out the completed lodge?
I guess?
If I'm done everything, I can go to the lodge and be like, here you go!
Right?
Oh, where is it?
Oh, right. Wrong game.
Here you go.
Yeah.
Assignment.
Oh, am I done for the day?
Look at the graphics, must have been like super great back then.
Why are you taking off your shirt, Steve?
Put on a shirt, you're gonna catch it cold.
That voice will always be hilarious.
Oh, yeah. Is this funny, Jill?
What's going on here?
Burger?
I was like there was just a burger there.
Anything that's suddenly in my thingy?
Obviously some fat high school girl left it here.
What the...
Dipper dolls.
Anything else?
No.
What do you want, Steve?
Still sick, huh?
Alright.
You wanna go?
You wanna go, little bro?
Okay, dad.
Is he feeling better?
You know what? Fuck you.
Goodbye.
Aw, man, I wanna kick Kim in.
newborn baby.
Dad?
Is there anything else?
Cookies? More cookies.
You forgot to have fun with mom yesterday.
So...
You want me to fuck mom?
Is that what you're saying? To do my ma'am?
I think I got a paper yesterday.
I think I have a paper from yesterday.
Yeah, I have a paper from yesterday.
Oh, hi. What? The game loves you!
See, she's like naughty words.
So I just put in a lot of naughty words, okay? Here.
See?
And not me! The game says it.
See? See, it's not me! The game says so.
Okay, hold on. I got your paper, boy.
There now. See how easy it is?
Things are so much better between us when you remember the paper in the morning.
And let's keep it that way.
I feel like this kid's gonna grab a gun at me or something.
Or stab me.
I didn't think that would happen.
I didn't think it would happen, but it did!
I knew it!
I knew it was strapped!
Can I punch him to death though? Is that a possibility?
I don't want to do this, but...
No, okay. It's only an outside thing.
It's possible, but very difficult.
It's just a really long time of punching.
The kid didn't even hesitate!
Can I kill the kid myself?
Whatever. We're gonna play a friendly relation for now.
For now.
Hey Steve, you've been doing a swell job putting the paper out in the morning.
You just keep doing that and we won't have any problems.
Yeah, yeah, whatever kid.
Where should I go to first? The lodge, right?
Yeah, I guess.
Yeah, I want to know what you know.
Okay.
Yeah, what kind of tasks?
Minor pranks!
There is, in harvest, a man named Mr. Johnson.
He owns a Tucker. It is his pride and joy.
I should like you to put a scratch in it.
A scratch? That's all?
As I said, a minor prank.
Mind you, you're not to damage the vehicle.
Really put a single scratch in it.
Once you have done so, return here.
And I shall give you your next task.
Okay, so I put a scratch on it.
Okay.
Do I...
What do I do? Okay.
If I do it right in front of him, he'll fucking kill me, right?
That's my guess.
What if...
What if I even use the scratch?
Shawty.
I want this.
I don't have money.
Hello, Steve. Care to buy anything?
No, thanks.
I'll be happy to help you.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, do I key a car?
Where can I get a key?
Maybe with the screwdriver? Where do I get the screwdriver?
Is he here?
He's not here.
Newspaper building.
Check the old man's garage.
This guy?
Sorry, Steve.
Bye now.
Can I go into his house?
Ew, okay.
I wonder if Stephanie has anything to say.
Oh, you're right.
I totally forgot about Stephanie.
I forgot! We have a wedding!
Yes, I... No, I haven't seen him.
Aw.
Wait, no, I shouldn't say aww.
You, you, you are dirty!
Okay.
But also, fuck you.
Not like in...
You forgot about your wife? Sure did.
You moved the people?
He didn't move the people!
Oi! Oi! Oi! Oi!
What did I say about the fucking people, huh?
You little shit.
I gave you one thing, and you didn't even do it!
Are you peeping caught?
Listen, I wanted to check if it was still there.
I wanted to check if it was still there.
Steve, I'm so glad you came back.
What have you been doing?
I visited the lodge.
Talked to the sergeant at arms there.
He knows that there's something out of whack here.
He told me if I wanted to find out what it is, I should join the lodge.
I've decided to join the lodge, Stephanie.
I think the answer to all our questions is inside.
That place.
It's so sinister.
Maybe, but I've got to join anyways.
You may be playing right into their hands.
Did you think of that?
Doesn't it seem like you're being hurted toward the lodge?
It's one of the things I hope to find out.
I hope finding out doesn't get you killed.
Come back and visit me soon.
Okay?
Okay.
Oi, that peephole!
Hole!
I guess.
Hmm.
You might want to be extra nice to Mr. Potson today.
Guess we're having a wedding at Mr. Moynihan's after all.
Give my regards to your parents.
Hmm.
You!
Hole!
My garage needs a new paint job.
I need a key. Where do I get a key?
I need a key.
Kittle, you brought me any of them girly picture books?
No, sorry.
Oh heck.
Why should you be any different from the sheriff or Mrs. Loomis?
Dave, I'd be right obliged if you could just seek Claire to bring in me just one of them books.
Believe me.
I already got your book!
I already got your one! What happened to the last one?
Wait, you're just going to let me look at it?
Can I do that again?
It just lets me?
It just lets me now?
Alright.
I'm a little nervous about it, but I guess it just does.
Alright, just don't mind me, officer.
I'm just going in.
I thought you were going to be burnt down already.
Bye.
Anything to stretch the car?
Have a shovel.
What's this?
A manhole key is stuck on the top of the manhole cover.
Can I take that?
Okay, bye.
Could you use the shovel and the manhole key? Why would I use the shovel and the manhole key?
Well, that didn't work.
Anything I can get to get it?
A lube.
Wait, was that not enough lube?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Wait, what do you mean I thought it sense?
Wait, what?
Was that the game?
I do remember there's...
Oh, that seems dangerous. Hold on.
Let's grab this.
Was that all I had to do today?
Okay.
The rest of the grate is bolted to the damp floor.
Cold and moisture has formed along the surface of the wheel valve.
Can I use it?
What about this?
Small section of the hull has been resealed due to the water damage.
Bolted.
Well, that didn't work.
Oh, man. Well, that didn't work.
Damn it.
What do I do now?
Is that just to go back up?
Okay.
Does that mean I have the brake in again?
Oh, man.
What do I need?
The walls down here?
Oh, there's a tiny indentation in the concrete.
Can I use the shovel?
Never mind, we got it.
Wow, wow!
Empty oil can slither before.
A large oil pan filled with lugs and bolts.
Oh.
Okay.
What's down here?
Mr. Johnson has a myriad of goodies on his tool bench.
Can I grab some?
Flashlight missing batteries.
Gas can similar to the model to the Postmaster's gas can.
Rubber mallet.
Ain't nothing but sawdust.
I was hoping he'd have a screwdriver.
Ducca ducca ducca ducca.
Oh, wait. No.
There it is.
Is there anything else here?
The edge to the side of the blowtorch reads,
Thinking of you, Edna.
How do I scratch this car?
Do I scratch it with the screwdriver?
Did it.
Get the fuck out of here.
Wait, can I cover the manhole?
Can I cover the manhole again?
Ah, man. Ah, man.
Yeah.
Fuck out of here.
Guess we go back to the lodge.
So, you have completed your first task.
Peace.
Now that you've scratched the ducca,
you may proceed to your second task.
You will steal a bolt of fabric from the fireman,
and bring it to me.
I see, then the lodge is comprised of thieves.
The human mind always seeks to categorize phenomena.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Meet again, huh?
Okay, I guess it's my day over?
Right, he talks a lot.
I guess we have to get the mob now.
Oh, I like the fireman's.
Well, that was fast.
I saw that faster than I thought.
Way faster than I thought, actually.
I just don't know why he's always got to be shirtless.
Does he go to bed with his watch on to use some pie?
I have, like, a kamigachi watch.
Oh, you're right.
He sleeps in jeans.
Many people would sleep with their Apple Watches nowadays
because the tracks sleep.
That's a bit luxurious for me.
Taddle shoes with laces knotted together.
Taddle shoes.
What's that?
I don't know.
Recently watered plastic plant.
Gotta get a paper.
Don't leave without it.
I said, don't leave without it.
Let's talk to your brother.
The dad feeling better?
Pot holder on her knees.
Reaching for him.
How can she do the stitches on him wearing those?
Wouldn't she slip?
Don't be silly.
She wouldn't do that.
Of course she'd slip.
Maybe that's why he's not getting better.
I heard that someone took Karen.
Little Miss Perfect was famous.
Gonna do a picture on her milk carton.
Yeah.
Well, I heard that Karen was gone.
So I went over to Miss Fitzgerald's house
and asked if I could play with Karen.
And I just stood there, you know, in the doorway
and cried and cried.
And I just stood there.
Punch my brother.
I don't know what take for her to stop.
But she didn't.
So I went inside and watched TV
because they've got color.
I thought you said you never heard of color.
Because she runs the diner and all.
And I've said she was feeling vulnerable.
So I asked her to fix me a peanut butter and jelly sandwich.
And she...
I'm gonna kill this kid.
Then I went into Karen's bedroom
and looked around for stuff I could take
while Edna was in the bathroom with the water running.
What?
But all that there was was pearl stuff.
So I came home.
But it was fun while it lasted.
You're evil.
Why is my brother off track?
Gosh, I wanna punch you.
Why can't I go over there and punch him myself?
Oops.
What?
What day did she disappear?
Tuesday.
Okay.
Wait, have I checked on my little sister yet?
Is my little sister even real?
What is wrong with that kid?
I hate kids.
Hold on.
What? Why?
Yeah, I did. Why?
What are we training?
Okay, sure. Take the sneakers.
Okay.
Don't you need the paper?
Paper?
Okay, you wanna go save Karen?
Yeah, I wanna go save Karen.
She seems like a sweet girl.
Wait a second.
Oh, so when did he talk about...
Okay, hold on.
Let's grab this.
Like, most security devices there
is usually more than one trap to stop intruders.
No!
When did I save?
What was the last time I saved?
Shit!
This is your first arrest, Steve.
Aw, man.
Next time I gotta save more.
Oh! It led me all the way here!
Son of a bitch.
Give me... Give me...
Right, go through the...
Wait a second.
A dependent poster?
Aided poster is a 1948 Sexiest Tomboy Award.
Tomboy, huh?
Did it.
No, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, you know what? Now we save again.
Oh my gosh.
Some pies. Are you saying that you like tomboy? Am I not tomboy enough for you?
More of you.
I hear tomboy.
I hear you.
Then I...
Uh-huh.
Mom says...
Good.
Oh, you go back here. Talk to mom again.
Hello, dear. By the way, it is...
This happened.
Don't forget to put...
Hmm, okay.
Now I talk to him.
Hey, did you...
Yes, I did.
You know this...
Take the sneakers.
Swirl.
And also the paper.
How do I get the alarm out then?
Hmm...
What's my definition of a tomboy?
Masculine traits?
Huh.
Okay.
How do we save her?
How do I... Fuck.
The alarm is in the living room, but your brother's a jerk.
I can try to get rid of that.
Oh, my God.
I want to kill him.
Where did she go?
I can't stop and chat, Steve.
With Karen gone, if I stop, I think I'll lose my mind.
I've got to keep busy.
Busy.
Excuse me.
I just heard that Mr. Johnson's tucker was vandalized.
You know, though I don't like to think ill of people
or take pleasure in the misfortunes of others.
I'd like to think it's a comeuppance
for all the people that I've met.
I've got to keep busy.
Busy.
Excuse me.
I'd like to think it's a comeuppance
for all the times that nasty man has bothered me.
I can't do it yet.
Yeah, let's check with Stephanie.
Oh, shit, wrong place.
Potsdam.
Did you say hello to your...
No, I haven't seen him yet.
His daughter, Karen, is missing.
How could anyone do something so terrible to her?
You think someone took her?
I think.
Oh, no, see, it was a kidnapping.
Haven't you heard?
The sheriff got a ransom note.
It seems someone wants to dip into Edna's lauder.
Too bad.
Such a bad thing.
I'm sorry.
Too bad such a sweet little thing
has to suffer.
Where were you Tuesday night?
That was a terrible night.
Our upstairs toilet backed up.
Pete Swell came over and fixed it.
My back still soar
from helping me carry his stuff up the stairs.
Someone went and scraped up Johnson's car?
Can you imagine?
He'd step in a bear trap
and chew his own leg off
rather than suffer a scratch.
Tucker serves the rich bastard right.
Okay, we're going all over the place.
Was Johnson behind the alibi?
I'm gonna just ask her.
Steve.
I'm sorry.
Want to hear what's happening out in the real world?
No.
I'd rather forget about Harvest for a while.
Come here.
What?
Stephanie.
I feel so close to you, Steve.
Like we're the only two people in Harvest.
The only two real people.
Do you know what I mean?
Yes?
I need to feel something again.
The sense I have that I've known you.
It's my only link to my past.
Yeah?
Maybe it's different than memory.
Okay, at least they just hold hands.
Yeah!
I had a nervous moment.
Strong feelings.
I'm so emo.
You would be too if you were all late.
Should I?
Should I do it, Chad?
I mean, surprise!
Then take me.
Now.
What?
Do you have the garden?
No.
Are we gonna be okay?
It's fine!
Is he still in there?
We're good.
We're safe, I think.
If it isn't my favorite son-in-law,
what brings you here again?
Huh?
Thank you for the $3.33.
Hey, Merce.
For a tiny-
Spiny?
Hi, Merce.
I apologize, but your son-in-law must go to sleep.
I'll try and watch the rest of the vlog tomorrow.
Good luck with the rest of the game, Kohai.
Okay, have good sleep.
Thank you for tuning in.
You!
Yeah, whole!
We spying!
What about Karen again?
Maybe I can talk to the mother?
Hello, dear.
Yes, please.
She's upstairs.
Have you heard that Edna's daughter, Karen,
has disappeared?
These things happen.
We just have to deal with them step-by-step
one day at a time.
Man!
Who told you about Karen?
Why, I suppose it was Mr. Poston.
Or maybe not.
I can't remember.
Please excuse me, Steve.
You seem flustered.
Not at all.
Everything is fine.
Hmm.
Can I talk about Karen again?
Sorry, I didn't catch that.
Nighty-sus.
Where were you Tuesday night?
Sorry, I didn't catch that.
Tuesday?
Sorry, I didn't...
I don't think nothing happens with her
if you just say fuck.
Sorry, I...
Give my regards to your parents.
Tuesday?
Interesting.
I might...
Oh, wait.
Was that a different animation?
Sorry.
Okay, okay.
I guess I'll just have to ask alibis, right?
Do I ask everyone?
Stop peeping!
It's a new animation!
Okay, so I messed up and
I didn't get mom's alibi.
So...
Let's go.
Hello, Steve. Care to buy?
Oh, thanks.
Okay, dear.
Come back soon.
Steve, you live close to Mr. Johnson.
How is he taking it?
Such wanton vandalism.
It just breaks my heart.
I'll have to send him a nice fruit basket.
Though if he wants some new paint and sealant,
it'll cost him.
Heavens, did you hear that Karen has disappeared?
I saw her playing outside the wayward hotel
on Tuesday night.
The night she vanished.
Did she seem upset?
Wayward hotel, huh?
Betsy, no.
She was under adult supervision.
So I didn't think anything of it.
You mean Edna was with her?
No, not Edna.
A man.
Or an inordinately large woman.
Large man or woman, huh?
Alright.
Large man or woman?
Sorry, son.
No time to talk.
Neither.
Next time you post.
Large...
men...
or women?
Hold on.
Is it...?
There's...
two large men...
I think.
That would be...
Johnson...
the sheriff...
and...
Mr. Potsdam.
Think about taking some of that sighting off my hand, son.
Okay.
I'll cut you a nice price on it.
Too bad about Edna's daughter going missing.
That was a strange night.
I remember that evening.
The Potsdam's upstairs bathroom toilet packed up.
I've seen folks upset about that stuff.
But Mr. Potsdam was just...
furious.
Hey, they even got it downstairs.
They got it downstairs, brother.
I thought he was working with you!
Well, that's a sure sign...
that civilization is coming to an end.
I don't think it was aliens.
Uh...
I don't want to hear about Tuesday.
Lights in a cemetery.
Give me a second.
I want to see the note they got at the police station.
Boy,
the way you keep pestering me,
you'd think you were feeling guilty about something.
Are you?
I understand you witnessed Ms. Whaley's
dispensing a little discipline at the school.
And she thinks you may be
feeling a mite bent about it.
Am I in my own business, Sheriff?
That's always the wisest course, boy.
Sticking your nose where it doesn't belong
can get you in a world of trouble.
Especially if you're a gynecologist.
Heck, there isn't a psychiatrist
around who disagree about
what a calm and influential
dent in the head.
Calm and influential?
If you argue with science, Steve,
it's bigger than all of us.
I got a report here that someone
put a ding on Johnson's tucker.
As honoured as Johnson is about
that old car, I suppose
he had it coming.
I imagine it was just some kids pulling a prank.
I suppose you've
heard the news about Edna's daughter, Karen,
disappearing.
What should I say?
Yes, I'm very concerned.
Or no,
Karen vanished?
What should I say?
One?
Okay.
I wouldn't think about it too much
if I were you.
This is a serious crime.
And this is no time for civilians
to be nosing around playing cops and robbers.
What about civic responsibility?
Steve,
I'd give this advice to my own son
if I had one.
Leave this be.
This is not the kind of thing you should look into.
I'm being paid off.
So some wild oats, boy.
Kick up your heels.
Join the lodge.
Join the lodge, Steve.
And leave Karen to the professionals.
Stop on by any time.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
I don't feel a...
any time.
Where's the note?
You said there was a note. Where's the fucking note?
I can't stop and chat.
That's it.
It's Stephanie's forge.
Hold on.
Flashing lights in the cemetery, right?
Well, that didn't work.
Can I move this?
I moved it!
Oh, my God!
Thank God I found you.
Are you all right, Karen?
I want to go home.
I'll be right back.
I found you.
Are you all right, Karen?
I want to go home.
Could you take me to my mommy's store?
Or to the policeman?
Can you tell me who did this to you?
Mr. Potstan
told me he'd hurt my mommy
if I told.
Won't do anything, I promise.
Tell me what happened.
He made me play house.
Then he dug a hole.
Please.
Can you go home now?
Can you tell me your address, honey?
I don't know.
Just take me to the store
or the policeman.
Please.
Mommy said to go to the policeman
if I got lost.
And I'm lost.
Bye bye.
What do you mean bye bye? We need to take you home!
How do I...
What do you mean bye bye?
We need to take you home!
How do I take her home?
What do you mean bye bye?
I don't trust the police.
I'm going back to the store.
What the hell?
Bring it! Thank you.
Bye bye.
I can't talk now.
The dishes are stacked up.
Okay!
I have money now!
I have money, right?
To the store?
And buy things?
Oh shit. I should save the game!
I should save!
Wait.
Where's the money?
I borrowed money.
I want that.
And I want this.
Oops.
Did I make a mistake?
That should cover it.
These 1950s prices are cheap.
Take what you need.
I don't need anything, right?
Wait. I need that.
I think that's all I need?
Yeah.
Are we going to be able to complete this game tonight?
I don't know!
No thanks.
Can I go down?
Thanks.
Where's the closet again?
This one?
Maybe I should save.
Save game.
Well that didn't work.
Oh man.
Wait. Which one is it?
Guys! Which one is it?
I couldn't get up in the morning.
It feels kind of dark so I can't tell what time it is.
What time it is?
What's up?
Get a tap?
Okay.
Can I go into the inn?
I don't think I've been to the inn yet.
Why are you talking like that?
Oh we have to steal the mall, right?
But why does he...
Why is he like...
ETA big sale.
Door is locked.
Ugh.
I have several places I can set fire to.
Should I set fire?
Not set fire.
Should I do the...
Barbershop?
Let's save at the barbershop.
Okay.
Straight lace...
Slot screws...
Does the fill-up work with it?
Well that didn't work.
Yeah, it has a sprinkler system.
Which is why I was wondering...
I could use it.
Well that didn't work.
What about...
The school's fire alarm?
What about the school's fire alarm?
I gotta get out of here.
I can get an axe.
I can get a ladder too.
Wait, how do I get in?
Wait someone, how do I get in?
You just go in.
It's not letting me, just go in.
Wait what?
There a hole in the second story window?
Are you sure I can just go in?
Damn it.
Okay.
What?
Try a ladder?
A ladder on what?
How do I get in?
Okay.
I don't get it.
Oh man.
Help!
Help, help!
Am I supposed to go to the school then?
Help!
Okay, but I want to go into the place.
I have to get out in at night?
Aw.
Give me back my key.
Okay.
No?
Which is the closet?
All the alarm at my house?
Okay.
What do I just push it?
Of the axe?
Do I use the ladder then?
Damn it.
Uh, wrench?
Use axe on brother, I would do that.
He didn't care.
Do I use the ladder here?
Okay.
Oh man.
Hmm.
I should change to a magnifying glass, huh?
Is it changing?
I think you need a furniture dolly.
A dolly?
What am I going to get a dolly?
Okay.
How are you not tired?
I'm a bit tired, but I want to finish this day first, Senpai.
I want to finish this day first, and then maybe we can, you know...
Okay.
Then we move on to the next day.
Oh man.
Okay.
I'm not, I don't have the same stamina as Shibi or...
...our mummy.
But I do, I am kind of like oof.
Tired.
Is there a dolly here?
Mr. Johnson's garage?
Oops.
Fatboy, well I'll make the carrot.
I'll make the carrot.
Fatboy, huh?
What do you mean?
I messed it up for you.
What?
Can I go in here?
Oh.
Okay.
Anything else I need?
I can just go in and out, huh? That's kind of weird.
What? Why?
Okay, bye.
Suddenly the dialogue came back?
Okay.
What's this?
Turn off the alarm system.
Okay, let's save here.
What? Undo the screws?
This photograph is a constant torture for borrowed dad.
Exotic kinky love equipment.
No, leave that there.
If any of it turns up missing.
Marv, what's going on in there?
Go! Go!
Wait, no dad, I need you. I need you to sign this first.
I need some meat, and Pat won't give me any without your sign permission.
Good old dependable Pat.
Here son, here's my signature.
Take it to him, and you won't have any problem.
Now go son, go quickly, before she comes back.
Not yet, dad, I want to talk to you.
Are you my father? Really? I don't remember you.
Please. I'm not in the mood for jokes.
I'm serious, why won't anyone believe me?
Oh my gosh, that's all you care about?
Just don't make me laugh now.
Remember the stitches? My God, what has she done to you?
She doesn't know you're here, does she? Does she?
No, I had to break in. What the hell is going on in here?
I know it's a mystery to you.
The sacred things that husband wants you behind closed doors.
Maybe we should have the special father's son dog.
The special father's son dog?
Yeah, I'd like that.
Okay. Yeah?
And bolt it with at least three locks.
At least three?
Aww.
They close on the woman, and then they...
With the barbed wire, they...
That's all right, don't get worked up. You need your rest.
Yes, rest.
But why did you come?
You must have had a reason for risking it.
I need some meat, and Pat won't give me any without your signed permission.
Good old dependable, Pat.
Here, son. Here's my signature.
Take it to him, and you won't have any problem.
Now go, son. Go quickly, before she comes back.
This is no time to talk, gibberish. Get out of here.
Now!
I love you, Dad.
This is no time to talk.
Love?
Okay. Bye, Dad.
So do I put it back?
Well, that didn't work.
Aw, man.
Huh.
Okay, well...
At least...
I don't know what to do.
Okay, well...
At least...
Dad taught me the last words.
With his last words about what...
What the...
You know, married couples do.
Yeah, Dad taught us a lot.
Well, that didn't work.
That won't happen to us, right, Kohai?
Just be good.
I guess I'll go to the meat plant.
And I'll give myself some meat.
Well, that didn't work.
So, your father okayed the meat, huh?
How's he doing?
Um...
Two? Two?
What if I say the first one?
Will I get in trouble? Will I die?
I should save first.
No, I can't save right now.
I can't save right now.
Okay, fine.
First one, first one.
He didn't care.
Wait, why is it nighttime already?
Did I, did I...
I didn't even get the firefighter stuff.
Wait.
Stop, Steve.
Dead.
Yes.
Yeah, you gonna rat on me?
Here?
Yeah.
Somewhere, huh?
Darkness vaults.
I forgot what he said.
Huh.
Okay, fine.
Huh!
Well, that didn't work.
All right.
Can I turn it off now?
Do I have it?
Yeah, I got it.
Thanks.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go now.
Uh, see ya.
This game is so crunchy.
Well, this game is from what year was this game out?
When year did this game come out?
Arvester game.
1996.
Okay.
It's old.
I can't believe.
He sleeps in jeans.
Steve sleeps in jeans.
Yes.
What do you people want from me?
Welcome to our Horde, the land that grips the life of its death.
Stephanie.
1996 is old? Do you know when the internet was made?
Senpai. Do you know when the internet was made?
When the internet went public?
95. This is one year after. Okay?
Oh my gosh.
Well, we're gonna save here.
I'm tired.
I'm tired, and I think I want to take a nap.
Well, a big sleep.
I want to take a big sleep.
I think about...
Don't look Senpai. Don't look at my steam. Don't look.
I don't know why it does that.
Okay.
Alright. Senpai.
This tomorrow will be the end, officially the end of the first week since debut.
Tomorrow I'll be playing Death Mark.
So...
And that will be probably the final of the genre of games that I like the most.
And that is the preview of all facets of me, Mercy Modest.
So, you can, as you saw, those were all games that I particularly...
genre of games that I particularly like. I feel like...
I feel like my point-and-click love really shone through in today's stream.
So, I think that this is probably a good one.
Honestly, I'm super invested. This is why I love point-and-clicks.
I really love point-and-clicks because they are definitely a genre I really love.
It's a genre that I grew up with. It's a genre where it's a lot of storytelling
and a lot of problem solving, and that's like some things that I really like.
So, honestly, I want to play more point-and-clicks.
We're definitely going to return to Harvester, hopefully.
When I stream it next time, I can finish it, hopefully.
And yeah, I played a lot of point-and-clicks. I played a lot of point-and-clicks. A lot.
So, if there's a chance I can play another one for Senpai's, I think I'll be great.
Will you be playing Miss Slash the Riven series? I'm not sure.
Miss is kind of 3D, right? I might. I might.
Oh, what else?
I might take a day off my schedule for next week's stream simply because I'm really exhausted Senpai.
A week of full streaming, no breaks. I'm really exhausted Senpai.
Tomorrow, yeah, we're playing Death Mark, which is a visual novel game.
I played it a bit, but I took a huge break from it, so it will feel like starting fresh again.
And I don't remember a lot of the puzzles or the gameplay, so we should be fine.
What else? What else?
Oh yeah, and tomorrow, I probably won't be late, but I'm really looking forward to it because my IRL friends are going to treat me to sushi
because they're like, congratulations on getting into Fialor, so I'm very happy.
I'm very happy that I can go meet out with my friends, but I probably am going to cut it short so I can come back and stream.
Are you going to be altering the times you stream? No.
Now, Fialor has kind of divided everyone into certain time slots to cover a variety of time zones, and I've taken over this time slot.
So unfortunately, I will be streaming all my streams to be at the same time, will start at the same time every time.
I'll see, except for, I think, when there are collabs, when there are collabs or special occasions, then I think the time is going to be a little bit more off.
Unfortunately, is it not a good time for you? I worry it's not a good time for senpais, because I know there are some senpais that want to catch me,
but unfortunately, I'm not matching their time zones. I hope that makes sense.
This makes me a little sad that some senpais won't be able to watch me.
I'd really like to cater to awesome pies, but at the same time, I don't want to overlap completely with my gen mates as well.
And we all start at certain times, which makes us available, like all of us available for our certain times.
So I feel bad that some senpais will be left out, which is why I say that.
So I still hope that the senpais that can't catch me will catch the vods, although I think there's something a little special about seeing things live,
which is why I feel a little sad, and that's why I say, unfortunately, instead of I'm glad.
I am glad that I get to have a time slot where I can do a lot of things in the daytime
and like be able to hang out with mama and papa and do my chores and just get ready for the day for stream.
And then at night time, I can stream and be like entertaining and I can be with my senpais.
But yeah, I feel a little bad that I can't cater to everyone, but I don't want to step on anyone's toes for their specific time slots as well.
I picked this time because it's the time where I'm kind of used to as well.
Yeah, at the end of the day, time zones are hard work for everyone.
Yeah, I'll try my best.
Maybe one day I'll schedule in some earlier streams, but once again, I kind of don't want to step on toes,
but I'll ask management if there's like a day where there's not a lot of, if many of my gen mates are having time off or something,
I can slip in a earlier stream.
I want everyone to enjoy Mercy Modi's.
Gorilla, I don't want to do gorilla all too much because I feel like if I do a gorilla stream that there are going to be some people who miss out and then they'll feel bad about it.
They'll feel like they've been left out, you know?
That's my feel on it.
I know that my gen mates will do it, but I feel like...
What is a gorilla stream?
It's a stream that's unannounced, so I just go on in the stream, you know?
Like, surprise! It's not on the schedule, but here we go!
So, I don't want my senpais to be like, I missed it! No! Or I didn't know she was doing that stream!
I don't want senpais to feel left out, so I'd rather schedule it.
If senpais really wanted to watch it, they can plan around it.
I feel like my gen mates are free to do what they want, but this is my own personal belief.
That's my opinion. It's my own personal belief, so don't think that the way that I think is going to be the way my gen mates think.
I'm very much a traditionalist in a way, so for example, my gen mates, they are free to talk about past lives and stuff,
but I'm definitely not a person who wants to discuss it, but not discuss my own personal past life.
I don't mind if they talk to me about their past lives, but I don't want to talk about my past life type of thing.
And I think the only times I'll ever do a gorilla stream is if I'm on vacation, but even then I'll feel bad for senpais who missed it, you know?
I know there's a lot of freedom and stuff within violor, but I'm still in kind of the idol mindset.
I'm very much in the idol mindset.
I don't know if there's like, you know, if there's a market for like an arrow idol.
But yeah, I think, I think, yeah, I'm very much pretty much a traditionalist.
I follow the JP formula a lot.
I hope that, honestly, I'm kind of like Strani.
I kind of want to have like the idol, the idol outfits, like the idol concert type of thing.
I know it's not traditional and some people might be very opposed to it.
Yeah.
Some people might be opposed to it, but it's kind of like, it's kind of my dream.
Senpai.
You know, it's a little bit of my dream to try to pursue being an idol.
Just a little bit.
It doesn't have to be completely, since all paths are strange.
But you know, ever since I watched Creamy Mami, I was like, I love this, I love this so much.
But my number one dream is, of course, to like, make my Senpai's happy and smile.
I really like, I really like that show, though.
I love the song.
Any specific idol outfits you like?
I kind of like the, they're all kind of like marching band slash military-esque.
I kind of like the pastel colored ones.
And the ones that are like, the one that are kind of poofy, like poofy skirts.
Thank you, Anonymous, for the 420.
Yeah, blaze it, or whatever them kids say.
What do you mean, peculiar aesthetics?
It's just the idol look.
Creamy Mami will be our next home marker.
No, no, no.
I think Creamy Mami will be too long for, and I think Creamy Mami is also a little bit harder to digest for Senpai's because of its age.
Being a very early Magical Girl series, it's also very long.
So I feel Cardcaptor Sakura is digestible and that it can be marathoned, but Creamy Mami, I don't think, is a marathonable.
Not Minky Momo.
Minky Momo is, it was definitely a wild ride.
But I feel like Cardcaptor Sakura is kind of one of the things that I really appreciate.
I won't lie to Senpai's, but Cardcaptor Sakura literally got me through some really hard times.
She literally saved my life.
Oh hi, look up the Curse of Minky Momo.
I already know the Curse of Minky Momo.
I know, I know it, I know it.
And if you, if Senpai's don't know it, just, I think, who's the YouTuber that covers it very well?
Kenny Lauderdale?
Yeah, that YouTuber covers it quite well.
The original, right? Not the Novana dub. I actually grew up with the Novana dub, but I love the original.
I think both of them are really good, actually.
The Novana dub, people are like, oh, it's bad, whatever. I think it's still a little bit, I think, despite it being a dub,
I feel like this voice is suited the characters quite well.
But Sakura has a saying that she keeps on like a mantra that she says,
and I've used that mantra to get through hard times a lot, which is, surely everything will be alright.
So that's gotten me through, like, really tough times.
Truly, surely, whatever, it's the same, it's the same mantra.
So, yeah, Cardcaptor Sakura literally saved my life.
So, uh...
So, Senpai's will have to watch it, too.
Understood?
Actually, the other day, I went to GameStop and I saw the clown wand, and I was like, oh, so I got it.
I got the wand, it's right underneath my desk.
You don't have to watch Clear Card.
I think for Senpai's homework would be just Season 1, Season 2, and then the two movies.
So, the two movies will be the Cardcaptor Sakura, the movie, and then Cardcaptor Sakura, the sealed card.
That'll be the second movie.
So, yeah, I ended up buying the wand.
A few years ago, my friends funded, put together some money, and then they got me the Sakura wand, you know, the Star Wand.
They got me the Star Wand, and I was like, yeah!
My wand, my angel's wand!
Well, you ever have Movie Night in a Discord?
Um, there's no Discord.
There's fan Discord, but there's no Discord.
Sorry.
Did you do a pose with it before?
Oh, yeah, I did.
I did like the classic little, like, heal, heal down, and she, like, does the, when she captures a card.
Did we use Discord?
Yeah, we have a work Discord, and the Discord for work we can also chat in, but not a, like, official fan Discord.
There's a, I think there's a Discord just for stream announcements, too.
I don't think it would happen, though.
I don't think a Discord where the girls are in will happen.
Simply because of safety reasons.
Because of safety reasons, Senpai.
There's a...
I'm not saying you, Senpai, will use it maliciously, but there are lots of other people who will use it maliciously.
Which is why, um...
Which is why we probably won't have a Discord, but we can interact with you through stream, YouTube comments, Maros, and on Twitter.
So there's lots of avenues to, um, talk to, to talk to us as well.
We might not always reply simply because there's just a lot of messages, but I'm always thankful.
And I'm sure that my gen mates were also very thankful for all the kind messages that everyone leaves as well.
So yeah, I might not always respond, but I will, I do, I do see it.
I do see it.
Yeah, Lori Kostrani's home for sad girls.
I think we're very happy now, actually.
We're very happy.
I mean, like, let's be real, though. If you're a VTuber, you have some kind of metal Illinois.
But...
But, uh, it's definitely...
All of us have our struggles, but, you know, we're here to entertain.
In the end, we're here to entertain.
And VLR has six wonderful talents for everyone to indulge in.
I'm trying to wink, but I have an eye patch.
Hahaha.
You need an account to send in tomorrow?
Uh, not necessarily, but if you want any of the girls, including myself, to reply, there's a chance that we'll reply privately.
So if you want to be responded to privately, that would be, uh, you need an account.
Hahaha.
But if you don't mind the question just being, like, posted publicly on, like, the Mara Wall, then that's it.
Sometimes I don't respond. I'm not...
Because I feel like if I say thank you over and over, I just sound like a broken record, and I feel like I don't want to fill the Mara Wall completely with all my thank you.
So I keep the Maros that are, like, compliments and saying nice things close to my heart instead.
Hahaha.
Also, yes, it's anonymous so that, um, so that there's still kind of a safety barrier for not only you, Senpai, but for us as well.
Oh, yeah.
Haha.
So yeah, you...there's many avenues in which you can interact with us, so it's not too bad.
It's not too bad, even if we don't have a Discord.
But yeah, no Discord is a safety thing.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
So I think that's it. I think that's it.
Hmm.
I say any more questions, Senpai.
I'm willing to answer maybe a couple more if any any questions about Villalor, uh, props up.
If not, I think we're done for today. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just feel the stream for six hours again, all high.
Well, it feels like it's gonna be probably the norm.
I just considered the powerhouse of the south of the mitochondria.
Hahaha.
Will you be Justin Idol or a magical girl idol?
Probably Justin Idol, a regular idol.
Oh, by the way, what's today's English word? Right.
Because, because mama, mama, those sort of things that your student sort of, but like has recently called you fans.
Let me think.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. I don't want to use another D word, even though D words, uh,
D words, D words are, D words are always on the mind.
How about. Hmm. Meek.
Let's see, let's use the word meek today.
M-E-E-K. Meek.
Quiet, gentle and easily imposed on.
Use it in a sentence.
Use it in a sentence is, you know.
Um, Mercy Maudiste is sometimes very meek.
Hahaha.
Yeah, that's our word of the day.
Thank you for joining me, Senpai.
And I hope to see you again awfully tomorrow. Okay?
Hehehe.
Are you ready?
Wait, wait, I forgot to say, are you ready?
But then I was like, can I, can I raid someone?
I think it's very light, so I don't have anyone to raid into.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, I don't have anyone to raid into.
So, it's just gonna be the end of the stream now.
So, ready?
One more time.
Ah, ah, ah.
Stream for Mercy!
Bye-bye!
Mwah!
Where is it? There it is.